Hello, believe Nation. I started the MentorMe
series with the goal of trying to learn from
people who've done a lot more than us by surrendering
ourselves with them a little bit more than
usual to get their ideas and wisdom and the
way they think to help us break through our
limited beliefs and become the best version
of ourselves.
So today we're gonna learn from Wayne Dyer
on how to stay motivated. As Wayne is talking,
if he says something that is really relevant
and helpful to you, please leave it in the
comments below and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired as well.
And these top 10 principles, uh, that I have
put together here for this program, uh, you
might want to jot down, you might want to
go into your, uh, uh, desk and just take out
a little piece of paper. But I think if you
practice them and look at them and see them,
they come from someone who's had a burning
desire, but has also been living a life in
which I have felt independent of the opinions
of others in terms of whether or not I should
or shouldn't be doing that there's something
that I allow to consult myself within myself
rather than looking outside to see if this
is right or not.
And so let me just kind of, I'll number them
and I'll go through them and I'll give you
some examples of them and you decide whether
they're to your liking and whether they work
or not. The first of these principles came
from a, uh, Adon scholar on the, in the 10th
century. His name was Tilopa. It's, uh, it's
not exactly bestseller books, but it's the
kind of thing that really excites me because
I think of going back a thousand years or
2000 years and reading what some of the greatest
minds had to say and how open they were to,
uh, the potentiality that each and every one
of us have for greatness.
And this first principle says, As to lopa,
put it, have a mind that is open to everything
and attached to nothing. One of the central
principles of my life is that no one knows
enough to be a pessimist about anything. And
that each and every one of us, when we close
our mind to what is possible for us, or what
is possible for humanity, closes off the genius
that resides and lives in each and every one
of us.
Having an open mind doesn't necessarily mean,
uh, finding fault with all of the things that
you've been taught by others. It means opening
yourself up to the potentiality and the possibility
that anything and everything is possible.
So, having a mind that is open to everything
and attached to nothing really means finding
within ourselves the ability to get rid of
a trait that I find so common in contemporary,
in the contemporary world.
Do you know that most people that I meet spend
their lives looking for occasions to be offended?
They actually are up out there hoping that
they can find some reason to be offended,
and there's no shortage of reasons. They're
out there everywhere. The way this person
dressed, the what the worst person said, they
turn on their tv, they hear the news, they're
offended by this.
Someone didn't, uh, someone used language
that they didn't like. Someone doesn't share
the same customs that you and people all day
long. In fact, if you keep track tomorrow,
you will find, uh, probably a hundred reasons
that you can go around being offended. But
a mind that is open to everything and attached
to nothing is a mind that says, I'm never
looking for anything to be offended by.
And that whatever anybody else out there has
to say, my response to that is, that's an
interesting point of view. I've never considered
that before. I remember, uh, being interviewed
for a, uh, morning television show, uh, and
the woman that was interviewing me said, how
does it feel to be talking to, uh, audiences
where people have all of these strange beliefs,
these weird things that they come to?
And it, it, it intrigues me because one of
the, uh, one of the things that, uh, that
Emerson said is in one of his very first essays,
he says, the first thing we have to say, respecting
what are called new views here in New England,
where we are right now, is that they are not
new, but the very oldest of thoughts cast
into the mold of these new times.
And that was in 1842. He was speaking about
that. And this woman asked me the question.
She said, uh, doesn't it offend you that there's
out, there's people out there and they're
talking about people using crystals to heal
somebody? And I remember my response, , my
response was that if I've got hemorrhoids
and somebody out there is convincing me that
crystals are gonna heal them, I'm ordering
crystal chairs.
I'm, uh, . Why not? I mean, all you have to
do is understand something called a placebo
and what is a placebo? It's nothing more than
a convincing belief. If I hand you this pill
and say, this pill is gonna cure your arthritis,
and you take it and the pill is just a sugar
pill, but your arthritis disappears, I'm into
buying those placebos.
Where can I get some of those placebos? and
it's true of everything. And it's when you
think about all the things that we enjoy and
what our life is like, um, it took people
who had a mind that wasn't closed to allow
us to make the progress that we've made. Progress
is imp is impossible if you always do things
the way you've always done things.
But the other word in this, what Telepo said
is be attached nowhere. Be attached. Nowhere.
Attachment really means I am diluting myself
into a belief that if I can't have, or if
I can't do this or that thing, then somehow
I am going to become immobilized. So an open
mind that is detached in one of, uh, in my
most recent book, in a spiritual solution
to every problem, I have a, um, an observation,
and it's, uh, an observation from Anthony
DeMelo, A man I respect enormously.
A priest who, um, in the way to love puts
it this way. Here's a great test for your
relationships, especially the relationships
that you're in, uh, with, uh, those whom you
love, not your children, but your spouses
and your lovers and and so on. Try this test
on for size one, I am not really attached
to you at all.
I am merely diluting myself into the belief
that without you, I will not be happy. And
two, and here's the toughest test for non-attachment.
I leave you free to be yourself, to think
your thoughts, indulge your tastes, follow
your inclinations, behave in ways that you
decide are to your liking. How's that for
a challenge?
And so what most of us do, In our relationships
and why they are not as successful as we would
like them to be is that we become attached
and we tell ourself that if this person behaves
in a way that I find offensive, then I can't
be happy. I make my happiness, my fulfillment,
dependent upon those people that I love being
what I think that they should be.
And detachment doesn't mean being a victim,
it just simply means I know that I can make
my life fulfilled and happy by having a mind
that is open to everything and attached nowhere.
The second principle is a very simple principle.
It says You can't give away what you don't
have. Now, it sounds ridiculous, okay?
But it's more than what meets the ear. As
you hear this, you can't give away what you
don't have. People who are not good at giving
away love can't give away love because they
don't have it to give away. If I want to give
you a dozen oranges, I can't give you those
dozen oranges unless I go out and pick up
12 oranges someplace.
Otherwise, all it is is just empty rhetoric.
And the same thing is true of virtually everything
in your life. You can't give away love for
others if you don't have love in here to give
away. If what you have in here is contempt,
if what you have in here is anger, if what
you have in here is fear, then these are the
things you're going to be giving away in your
life.
And I've often thought, and I really believe
very strongly, that uh, there's a law, sort
of a law in the universe. I call it the law
of attraction. And the law of attraction is
one that works like this. You get back from
the universe, from the world what it is that
you put out there in the world. And if you
are putting out there into the world that
I am not worthy of attracting something beautiful
into my life, that the universe will respond
back to you with exactly that message.
And there are people who come to me and who
came to me for years when I had a, uh, my
own, uh, counseling practice and so on. And
they would say to me, um, I just keep attracting
the same kind of people, the same kind of
events, the same kind of, uh, losers into
my life. Why is that? Why do I keep doing
that?
And I keep attracting, uh, an absence of,
uh, of abundance. I just can't seem to attract
abundance into my life. I'm always behind
the eight ball. I'm never getting ahead. And
I suggest to them, I said, did, uh, ever occur
to you that that's the very kind of message
you're sending out to the world and out to
the universe, that the ocean of abundance
is there.
And you can go to that ocean of abundance
and you can take a Mac truck and you can fill
it up 20 times a day and take it out of there.
And guess what? It doesn't impact at all the
ocean of abundance. It doesn't even go down
a zillion of an inch. It's unlimited. Or you
can go to the same ocean of abundance with
a eyedropper, and you can just take this much
out once a month and say, that's all that
seems to be available for me.
And the interesting thing for me is that when
people go to this ocean of abundance, this,
uh, unlimited world, all that I have is nine.
It says in the Holy Books, all that I have
is th it's all there for you. But if you believe
inside that it's limited, that you can only
get so much. That other people are gonna get
it before you do, then you'll find yourself
creating that very same thing.
And the even more interesting part about this,
you can't give away what you don't have. Principle
is that if your message to the universe is
gimme, gimme gi, which is a lot of people's
message to the universe, I want this from
you. I want that from you. Please give me
this. I have to have that. That's what their
prayer is like.
That's what their message is, you know? And
they say, I want this from the universe. Give
me gimme, gimme the universe's response back
to that kind of an, uh, mentality is exactly
the same. The universe will say Right back
to you over and over again. Give me, gimme,
gimme. And you'll find yourself never, ever
arriving, but always being in a state of striving,
always feeling as if you're being neglected.
Never feeling as if you have enough. Always
feeling as if you're being shortchanged because
you're constantly under the pressure to give,
to get back what the universe is demanding
from you. And the interesting thing about
all of this, the, the irony of this is that
if you shift that and you say to the universe,
to the world, how may I serve?
How may I serve? The universe's response back
to you is, how may I serve you? How may I
serve you? And it's very intriguing when you
take your energy and your attention off of
what you are demanding from the world. And
instead saying, what can I give to the world?
And it's really the, the basis behind that
very famous line of the, uh, president, uh,
John Kennedy's, uh, inaugural address.
Ask not what your country can ask, what you
can do for your country. And the irony of
that is, and I've learned that in my own life,
that when I stopped thinking about what was
in it for Wayne Dyer and how much could I
get, and I began to shift. And say, how can
I help you? How can I give to you? What can
I do for you?
And people who write to me pe uh, I send them
something. When, when I encounter somebody
that needs help with some kind, I'm very often
just giving that to them. And then I find
that it just keeps coming back into my life.
And once I shifted that energy off of what
can I have into, what can I give, it seemed
to me that the universe responded back with
the very same message.
What can I give to you? And the most incredible
and wonderful and beautiful abundance has
flowed into my life in every way that I can
possibly think of. You can't give away what
you don't have. So take a look at an inventory
of what you do have. How much do you love
yourself? How much kindness do you have in
you?
How much peace do you have in you? How much
joy do you have in you? And if you're able
to give that away as many times as you can
in a given day, watch and see how much more
of that continues to show up and come back
in your life. Okay, the third principle is
one of my very favors. It's called, there
are no justified resentments.
And this is a very difficult principle for
many people to get, but one that I believe
very strongly in. I was in a group one time
of, uh, drug addicts and alcoholics, and I
was, uh, one of the people that was a sponsor
and leading this group. And the sign on the
wall said, there are no justified resentments
in this group.
And what I said to that group that, that night
was, no matter what anybody says to you here,
No matter what kind of, uh, uh, anger comes
directed towards you, no matter how much hate
you may encounter showing up in your life,
there are no justified resentments. Meaning
that if you carry around resentment inside
of you about anything or about anyone, and
I'm talking about the person that you lent
money to and hasn't paid you back, I'm talking
about the person in your life that you feel
was abusive in your life.
I'm talking about the person who walked out
on you and left you for somebody else. I'm
talking about all of the things that you have
justified in your heart and in your life that
you have the right to be resentful about.
And I'm suggesting to you that those resentments
will always end up harming you and creating
in you a sense of despair.
I've often said that you, no one ever dies
from a snake bite. The snake bite will never
kill you. You cannot be un bitten. Once you're
bitten, you're bitten. But it's the venom
that continues to pour through your system
after the bite that will end up destroying
you. So now you have to take a look at all
of the resentments that you may have in your
life.
And I'd like to suggest to you that I think
there is a wonderful metaphor for this, that
I have created in my life for how to make
this work. And I think that Regis Philman
is the one who's responsible for it. All right,
my buddy.
There's a show called, uh, who Wants to Be
a Millionaire that has been popular all over
the world. I'm in South Africa, it comes on,
all right. I was in Australia and they've
got their own Australian version. Um, and
in Greece they have the Greek edition of,
uh, who Wants to Be a Millionaire. And basically
this show has two levels that you have to
get to.
Now, the first level is the $1,000 level.
And at the $1,000 level, you basically have
to answer a question. Like on your hand, you
have some digits. Those digits on your hand
are called your feet, your nose, your ears,
your fingers. Uh, and everybody, whoever goes
on the show has this horrible dread that they're
gonna go out on one of those questions.
right? So basically, in order to get to the
thousand dollars level, all you have to do
is answer five pretty simple, simple questions
in order to, uh, to get to the thousand dollars
level. Now on this program, the thousand dollars
level for you in this metaphor means that
you will leave with something. If you get
this, at least get this, this is the thousand
dollars level.
You must send blame out of your life. For
any conditions of your life. Blame has to
go. Alright? Now, blame means if you are sitting
there with a disease, you say, without guilt,
it's mine. I take responsibility for it. This
means that if you have been through any tough
circumstances in your life, this means if
you have a minimal amount of, uh, of financial
security in your life, this means if your
children don't, uh, get along with you.
This means that, uh, if your neighbors are
having taking up a petition to get you outta
the neighborhood, whatever it might be that's
going on in your life, you name it. And everybody
across the, this great country across this
world has a series of these things that you
are willing to say, I am here because of the
choices that I have made right now.
I'm willing to say that even though it's difficult,
and we know it's really not your fault, we
know really there's a lot of people out there
who are really bad. All right, . But, but
you're willing to say no blame. That's the
first level. All right? That's where you understand
no justified resentment. And then on, uh,
who wants to be a Millionaire Show?
There is what is called the $32,000 level.
And the $32,000 level is not only an opportunity
for you to walk away with a sizable amount
of goodies, which you can walk away from tonight
in this program, but it also is the door opener
to multi wealth. But you gotta get to this
in order to have an opportunity to move into
these transcendent levels.
All right, millionaire Spiritual, uh, status.
All right, you gotta get through these next
five questions. And this $32,000 question
or level rather, comes to this, it came to
me from a quotation that I used in the writing
of a spiritual solution to every problem.
I read the, uh, a book that was written a
couple of thousand years ago by Patanjali,
the Yoga Sutures, the aphorisms of Paton,
and one of those sutures, one of those aphorisms
observations that this brilliant man made
almost 2000 years ago was this.
He said, if you become steadfast in your abstentions
of thoughts of harm directed towards others,
all living creatures will cease to feel enmity
in your presence. Now, this translates to
blame. Pretty basic. No more blame. I'm just
not going to assign responsibility to other
people for where I am, because now I have
an opportunity to get rid of it.
If I think someone else caused it, then I've
gotta wait for somebody else to change in
order for me to get rid of it. And you might
wait forever for that. But if I take responsibility
for it, I can do something including move
on, which might be the most important thing
to do, alright? But at the higher level, when
there are no justified resentments, what you
are doing is what St.
Francis did. Francesco, what you are doing
is you are at a place where you are sending
love in response to hate. You are literally
saying, no matter what comes my way, I am
going to be steadfast in my abstention of
thoughts, of harm directed toward others.
I'm going to work hard at no matter what comes
my way, having it come out of me what I want
to come out of me.
And that is love. And that is a higher energy.
And if you can get to that level, Baton said,
all living creatures will cease to feel enmity
in your presence. I have a little girl, a
precious little girl. I have six precious
girls and two precious sons. But I have a,
uh, a little girl who is almost 12 and she
loves animals like no one I've ever met in
my life.
I mean, her whole life revolves around animals.
And when we walk in the woods, butterflies.
Avoid me fly away from people around, and
they come and they land right on her arm and
it happens all the time, all living creature.
She couldn't have a thought of harm directed
towards any living creature. And Pat potentially
said to us, all live creatures will cease
to feel fear or enmity or anger in the presence
of those who can send love in response to
the hate.
That's what I mean when I say there are no
justified resentments. What I'd like to do,
I'd like to share a little story here with
you. It's a very tender story. It was sent
to me by someone who sends me beautiful things
in the mail, and I call it the teddy story,
and I'd like to read this to you if I can
do it without tearing up.
And this story illustrates this as well as
anything I've ever seen. There's a story many
years ago of an elementary school teacher.
Her name was Mrs. Thompson, and she stood
in front of her fifth grade class on the very
first day of school. She told the children
a lie. Like most teachers, she looked at her
students and said that she loved them all
the same.
But that was impossible because there in the
front row slumped in his seat was a little
boy named Teddy Stoddard. Mrs. Thompson had
watched Teddy the year before and noticed
that he didn't play well with the other children,
that his clothes were messy and that he constantly
needed a bath. Teddy could be unpleasant.
It got to the point where Mrs. Thompson would
actually take delight in marking his papers
with a broad red pen and making bold Xs, and
then putting a big F at the top of his papers
at the school where Mrs. Thompson taught she
was required to review each child's past records.
And she put Teddy's off until last.
However, when she reviewed his file, she was
in for a surprise. Teddy's first grade teacher
wrote Teddy's a bright child with a ready
laugh. He does his work neatly and he has
good manners. He's a joy to be around. His
second grade teacher wrote Teddy's an excellent
student, well liked by his classmates, but
he's troubled because his mother has a terminal
illness and life at home must be a struggle.
His third grade teacher wrote His mother's
death has been hard on him. He tries to do
his best, but his father doesn't show much
interest and his home life will soon affect
him if steps aren't taken. Teddy's fourth
grade teacher wrote Teddy's withdrawn and
doesn't show up much interest in school. He
doesn't have many friends, and sometimes he
even sleeps in class.
By now, Mrs. Thompson realized the problem
and she was ashamed of herself. She felt even
worse when her students brought her Christmas
presents wrapped in beautiful ribbons and
and bright paper except for Teddy's. His present
was clumsily wrapped in his heavy brown paper
that he got from the grocery bag.
Mrs. Thompson took pains to open it in the
middle of the other presence. Some of the
children started to laugh when she found a
rhinestone bracelet with some of the stones
missing and a bottle that was one quarter
full of perfume. But she stifled her children's
laughter when she exclaimed how pretty the
bracelet was putting it on and dabbing some
of the perfume on her wrist.
Teddy Stoddard stayed after school that day
just long enough to say, Mrs. Thompson, today
you smelled just like my mom used to. After
the children laughed, she cried for at least
an hour. On the very day, she quit teaching,
reading, writing, and arithmetic, and instead
she began to teach children. Mrs. Thompson
paid particular attention to Teddy.
As she worked with him and his mind seemed
to come alive, the more she encouraged him,
the faster he responded. By the end of the
year, Teddy had become one of the smartest
children in the class, and despite her lie,
became one of her teacher's pets. A year later,
she found a note under the door from Teddy
telling her that she was still the best teacher
he ever had in his whole life.
Six years went by before she got another note
from Teddy. He then wrote that he had finished
high school third in his class, and she was
still the best teacher he ever had in his
whole life. Four years after that, she got
another letter saying that while things had
been tough at times, he stayed in school and
stuck with it.
It would soon graduate from college with the
highest of honors. He assured Mrs. Thompson
that she was still the very best and favor
teacher he ever had in his whole life. Then
four more years passed, and yet another letter
came. This time he explained that after he
got his bachelor's degree, he decided to go
a little further.
The letter explained that she was still the
best and favorite teacher he ever had, but
now his name was a little longer. The letter
was signed, Theodore f Stoddard, md. But the
story doesn't end there. You see, there was
yet another letter that spring. Teddy said
he'd met this girl and it was gonna be married.
He explained that his father had died a couple
of years ago, and he was wondering if Mrs.
Thompson might agree to sit in the place at
the wedding that was usually reserved for
the mother of the groom. Of course, Mrs. Thompson
did, and guess what? She wore that bracelet,
the one with, uh, several rhinestones missing,
and she made sure she was wearing the perfume
that Teddy remembered his mother wearing on
their last Christmas.
Together, they hugged each other and Dr. Stoddard
whispered in Mrs. Thompson's ear, thank you
so much for making me feel important and showing
me that I could make a difference. Mrs. Thompson
came with tears in her eyes and whispered
back. Teddy, you have it all wrong. You were
the one who taught me that I could make a
difference.
I didn't know how to teach until I met you.
Isn't that a beautiful story? Yeah.
That symbolizes, there are no justified resentments
work at reaching that $32,000 level. The place
where the only thing you have to send is love
because that's what's inside. And that's the
message of our greatest spiritual teachers.
That's all they ever had to give away. The
next principle I called, don't die with your
music still in you.
And who better to quote than Thoreau right
here in Concord when he talked about some
of us hear a different drummer and we must
march to the music that we hear. But all of
you, everybody watching everybody here in
this beautiful parish, all of you have some
music playing and all of you have a heroic
mission.
There's no accidents in this universe. We
all show up here with a purpose. There's an
intelligence that is a part of everything,
and everyone and all of us are connected to
it and too many of us are afraid to listen
to that music and march to it. You out there,
I know you have a book you wanted to write.
I know there's a composition you wanted to
compose. I know there's a song you want to
sing someplace. Maybe you wanna raise horses
out in Montana, or maybe you want to open
up an ice cream shop on Cape Cod. Who knows
what it may be. Maybe you just want to travel
and see the world. Maybe you want to go into
a relationship with someone, but you've been
afraid to, but your heart says it's the right
thing to do.
All of us feel something. And in Leo told
stories, famous novel, the Death of Ivan Illich.
He asked this question that would be terrifying
to me. He says, as he has his accountant from
Moscow lying on his deathbed, contemplating
the horror of this question, what if my whole
life has been wrong? I've known what my music
is.
It's playing right now. As I stand here in
front of you with these cameras and in this
place, and as I sit down and write my books
and tell the world what I know are my truths,
I feel always completely on purpose and fulfilled.
And no time will I ever come to the end of
my life and say, what if my whole life has
been wrong?
Whoever you are, whatever that music is, however
distant it may sound, however strange, however
weird others may interpret it to be, don't
get to the end of your life and know that
you're going to leave and not have it played
yet. Don't die with your music still in you.
It's the message of, uh, the greatest teachers
who've ever walked among us.
It's the message I give to you today as one
of the principles for success and peace in
your life. The next principle I call embracing
silence and embracing silence is not that
I say this to you because it's so important
to be quiet. What I have learned, I have a
dear friend and many of you know, we've put
out tapes together.
We've appeared on stages all over the world
together. He's like a brother to me. His name
is Dr. Deepak Chopra. A medical doctor and
a dear and close friend, and whenever anything
is going on in my family, if I'm having a
problem with one of my children or with my
in my own life, and if I call him up and I'll
say, Deepak or his wife, Rita, I'll say, Deepak,
what do you think I should do?
He always has the same answer. Meditate,
I'll say, yes, Deepak. I understand meditate,
but I said, what do you think? He said, Wayne,
go deep inside and meditate. Always meditate.
I'll say, will you put Rita on Wayne? Meditate?
I say, all right. And you know, I've learned
a lot in meditation, but what I know most
about getting quiet and getting peaceful is
this, that there's only one power in the universe
and it doesn't matter what you call it.
You can call it soul, spirit, consciousness.
God, you can call it Louise. You can call
it anything that you want, but as Alan Watts
said, you can't get wet from the word water.
It's not what we call something that gives
it its substance. And this one power, this
one force that flows through everything and
allows everything to be, is indivisible.
You can't cut it in half. You can't divide
it. It's one. It's knowing the one and everything
in your life is almost always given a division.
Male, female, young, oh, tall, short, black,
white, good, bad, up, down. These are all
dichotomies. These are all these splits that
we all have in our lives. The whole physical
world that we live in and are immersed in,
it's always immersed in this division.
I used to teach course at St. John's University
in New York, and I used to tell my students
when I was trying to teach this principal,
anybody who can come to class and bring with
them a magnet that only has a North Pole.
I'll give you an A in the course. You don't
ever have to attend another class. And no
matter how thin they would slice that magnet
, there was always the South Pole because
the physical world is made up of dichotomies.
But we have to learn to fuse the dichotomies
and infusing the dichotomy, dichotomies and
blending the want. That's what silence does
for us. That's why embracing silence is so
powerful because no matter how many times
you cut silence in half, it's like zero. You
still only get silence. And then they say
it's the, uh, it's the space between the bars
that holds the tiger.
And it's the silence between the notes that
makes the music. These words that are coming
out of my mouth right now come out of the
silence. And finding that silence and embracing
it means that you go to the place within you
that you cannot divide. Just like you can't
divide the source, the one, the spirit, you
can't divide that either.
It's only one. So when you go into your silence
and you begin to practice meditation, and
you begin to make this a part of your life
and embrace silence, what you discover is
this is where you'll come to know your source.
You'll make conscious contact with your, so
I can't tell you how many people that have
come to me who have suffered from serious
illnesses, who've been giving, given diagnoses
that it's terminal and that you can't do it,
who have gone out to the wilderness and have
decided that I am going to commune with nature.
And the Transcendentalists, Thoreau and Emerson,
they believed that nature was our source and
that we were all products of nature. And if
you can get back to your source, if you can
get back to that feeling of being with spirit.
That, that's where healing can take place.
And I've had wonderful stories of people who've
told me that it was when I began to embrace
that silence, that I began to feel more connected
to my source.
Embrace silence. Because it's a way to come
to know God, to know your source. Both are
indivisible and the only experience you can
have in your daily life that even comes close
to a spiritual awake awakening is silence.
The next principle I call giving up your personal
history. And I learned it from a man named
Carlos Castaneda, who once said that.
Um, one day he said, I finally realized that
I no longer needed a personal history and
just like drinking, he said, I gave it up.
And that, and only that has made all the difference
in the world. You know, the nice thing about
giving up your personal history is that if
you don't have a story, you don't have to
live up to it.
All of us have these bags, a manure that we
carry around with us called our past, and
the people who have done things to us and
the events and the circumstances, all of this
stuff that we use and we bond to, and we bond
ourself to these wounds of our past. And we
identify ourself on the basis of these wounds.
And every once in a while, we set it down
and we reach in there and we smear it all
over ourselves, . And then we wonder, why
does my life smell so bad? I don't understand
this. When in fact, the now, this moment,
merging yourself into the now means that you
may have been in a relationship. I had a woman
from Holland who came over to see me, whose
husband had left her after 25 years.
She had four children and she just had been
on the verge of suicide and she was losing
weight and she was depressed and she was taking
all kinds of drugs for it. And she was getting
sicker and sicker because she just couldn't
get over it. And she came to a book signing
that I was doing at a bookstore down in Florida
and she said, you've got to say something
to me.
You've got to say something to me that will
help me to get over this. And I told her this
line. I said, give up your personal history.
Merge yourself here now into this moment.
And those 25 years are something if you want
to understand how to do it, think of your
past as, oh, this hat, and this is your past
now.
You can't just set this thing down over here
and walk away from it and give up your personal
history because you'll always have it there
to look back at. What you do is you pick up
your past and you embrace it, you understand
it, you accept it as, I had to go through
these things that I had to go through in order
for me to get to this place today.
And the evidence for that is that I did. You
don't need any more evidence. You did. And
then you toss it. You toss it, you embrace
it, and you toss it and you merge into the
now by giving up your attachment. And some
of you have heard me use the metaphor of the
wake. Alan Watts talked about the wake is
not what drives the boat.
The wake is just a trail that is left behind.
That's all it is. And so is the wake of your
life. And the wake doesn't make the boat go
and neither does the wake of your life. The
reason why your life is going in the direction
that it is. The wake is a trail that is left
behind and it's an illusion to believe that
it is the cause.
Of your suffering or your struggles or your
difficulty. Give it up, let it go. Embrace
it, understand it. Get help doing that if
you must. And then move into the now the next
principle I call, it's from a line of, uh,
Albert Einstein. He said, you can't solve
a problem with the same mind that created
it.
In order to work at solving these things called
problems in your life, you have to change
your mind. It is your mind where they live.
It is your mind that created them. They there
is where you experience them. They're all
illusions. You must change your mind. Literally
rewrite your agreement with reality.
One of the things I had said earlier is that
one of the most difficult things to do in
the world is to admit that you were wrong.
Admitting that you were wrong is nothing more
than saying, I have been making choices with
my mind that have created things in my life
that are not working, and I no longer intend
to continue making those choices.
I was wrong. You don't have to make a declaration
of it. You don't have to go out and feel guilty
about it. You just simply say, it didn't work.
The relationship that I was in before I behaved
in these ways, I didn't realize that it wasn't
working for me. Now I do, and this is where
I choose to be. Now, the secret of a successful
relationship is to me, understanding that
you put your attention and your energy in
a person on what you love rather than what
you don't love.
Robert Frost said it so beautifully. We love
the things we love for what they are. For
what they are, not for what they ought to
be. Not for what they used to be, but for
what they are. So when you look into the eyes
of person you're in a relationship with, whether
it's your children, you catch them doing things
right as much as you possibly can.
That's often ta takes a lot of hunting, but
you'll find it. And when you think that my
relationship isn't working, remember, it's
in my mind. What am I thinking about that
person? And if I could just change my mind
and put my thoughts on what I love about this
person and keep them there, that makes the
relationship flourish.
And there are people who go through their
entire relationship history with no anger,
no hatred, no bitterness, and only love. The
next principle is, I call it treating yourself
as if you already were what you would like
to become. In other words, you get out in
front of your life and you see yourself as
having already what you know you'd like to
have and deserve to have.
My children know how to do this perfectly.
I have a daughter who wanted a prom dress,
and the prom dress was way outside the budget
that I thought a prom dress should be. Uh,
well, I thought a prom dress shouldn't cost
over $20. So I do have a problem. Huh. But
I upped to somewhere around 250. I don't know
how much, whatever.
To me, it was still more than I paid for my
first house. Okay. Uh, . But anyway, she called
and said, dad, this is the only prom desk
I could wear. This is the, I've got to wear
this prom desk. Don't wear this prom desk.
It's just on and on and on with this, uh,
wonderful. You know, I've got a, I saw a wonderful
book about how to raise teenage uh, daughters.
The title of it is Get Out Of My Life. But
First Drive Me and Cheryl to the Mall. All
right. That's a, that's the actual title.
It's a good. And so I told Serena, I said,
uh, it's just beyond the budget. I've got
a certain amount of money that I'm willing
to put for it. And, and she said, but I've
already seen myself wearing it.
I've already tried it on. I have a picture
of myself in the dress in my living room,
and I've already showed it to the guy who's
taking me to the prom. I mean, it was this
whole thing about, and she already saw herself
in it. I said, well, if you see yourself in
it, then you're gonna have to also see yourself
as earning the difference between what I'm
willing to pay
And she drew up a contract. She went out to
the computer and on the background of the
computer, you know where they have these little
background things they put on. There was 500
pictures of the dress, all right. And she
signed a contract and said, I'll babysit.
I'll do this. I'll do that, and I will pay
the difference.
And she did. And she wore the dress because
she understood that you treat yourself as
if you already are what you'd like to become.
There's a genius in you. You have to treat
yourself as if you already were that genius,
there's something you're completely capable
of. See yourself as already there. Then you'll
act upon those thoughts because the ancestor
to every action said Emerson is a thought.
The next principle is called treasuring your
divinity. Treasuring your divinity. There's
a wonderful observation that I saw from, uh,
from Emerson in self-reliance. It's about
trusting your divinity, knowing that you are
connected to your source, knowing that you
are a divine creation, and that there are
no accidents.
He said, A man should learn to detect and
watch that gleam of light, which flashes across
his mind from within more than the luster
of the firmament of Bards and sages. Yet he
dismisses without notice his own thought,
because it's his own. In every work of genius,
we recognize our own rejected thought.
They come back to us with a certain alienated
majesty. We often reject our thoughts and
we see the things that we think of as grand
and as genius, and we reject them because
they're our own treasuring, our divinity.
Instead of being terrified of it, knowing
that I am always connected to my source, there
is no way that I cannot because it is in you
and I am in you, and you are in me.
And you can never be separated from it. There
is no place that this source is not. It grows
everybody's fingernails. It beats everybody's
hearts. It digests everybody's foods. It opens
all the flowers and you're always connected
to it. And finally, the last principle I call
wisdom is avoiding all thoughts which weaken
you.
You know, every thought has an energy just
like everything else in the universe. And
if you have a thought of shame, it will weaken
your muscles. And what is your heart? But
a muscle. If you raise a child who believe
in shame and feel ashamed of themselves, every
time they think that shameful thought, they
will be weakened.
And if you have a thought of fear, and if
you have a thought of stress, and you have
a thought of anguish and anxiety, all of these
thoughts and many more are the thoughts that
will always weaken you. When you are having
a thought that you know is disempowering,
you shift it. Shift it to one that is empowering
rather than disempowering.
And the thoughts that empower our thoughts
of neutrality and willingness and love, and
ultimately thoughts of divinity. And when
you see a troubled person who is out there
struggling at the highest level of unity consciousness
or God consciousness or spiritual consciousness,
you recognize yourself in all that you see
there.
But for the grace of God, go, I, and I am
connected to that person, changing your thoughts.
I appeared on the, uh, tonight Show many years
ago, several times, quite a few times. And
I remember coming home from the Tonight Show,
and I was walking along the beach and they
had taped the show the night before. And I
was out for a walk.
And a woman who lived in, uh, the northeast
stopped me and she said, didn't I see you
last night on the, how could you be here?
I said, well, I flew the red eye and I was
walking along and she said, you know, we're
moving down here. She said, um, what are the
people like here? What's it like? And I said
to her, I said, well, what do they like where
you live?
She said, well, she said, uh, I live in a
very big city. And she said, uh, they're very
pushy and people are not very kind, and they
don't have time for you. And she said, uh,
it's really not very pleasant. She said, that's
one of the reasons I'm leaving there. I said,
well, that's pretty much what you're gonna
find here,
That's basically what the people are like
here. On the way back, on the same day, someone
else who had seen me the night before on the
Tonight Show, who had lived in the Midwest,
stopped me and asked me almost the same question.
She said, you live here? I said, yes. She
said, what? My husband and I are moving here
and we're looking for a school.
She said, what are the people like here? What's
it like here? I said, what are they like in,
in, uh, Chicago, where you live? She said,
oh. She said, it's the Midwest. She said,
people are very friendly. They're open. They
open their homes to you. They're very loving.
They're very kind. She said, it's a wonderful
place.
She said, I love them. I'm gonna really miss
that. I said, that's pretty much what you're
gonna find here, . It's what you expect. It's
what you think about that expands. It's what
Emerson taught us. The ancestor to every action
is a thought. Change your thoughts. and you
change your world, change your expectations,
and you change around what you begin to manifest
and see showing up in your life.
You are the sum total of all of the choices
that you've made up until now. And anything
about yourself or your life that you don't
like or isn't working or is Im mobilizing
you, is to be looked at in terms of can I
grow rather than why did I do it? Or isn't
this wrong? See, the two ways to motivate
yourself are deficiency motivation, which
says where I am, I don't like, I don't like
what I've done.
I don't like the fact that I can't do this
well, or I can't do that well. So I will list
these things in my own repertoire, and then
I will be constantly trying to repair those
deficiencies, always assuming that I'm deficient,
that there's something wrong with me and I'm
trying to fix it. And when you do that, you
spend your whole life doing that, and you
never arrive because your life becomes a series
of trying to get someplace else.
And it is if you follow that, if you live
that, if you behave that, then what you, what
happens to you is you become a person who
will always suffer from this disease called
more. You always have to have more because
whenever you are getting where you want to
go, let's say you want a hundred thousand
dollars in the bank and you work and you struggle
and you deny yourself, and you do all of those
things and you finally, finally you get there
and here you are, you got a hundred thousand
dollars in the bank.
All of this stuff over here is of course your
life. And that is all you know. That's what
you know how to, that's how you are. That
is your being. That is your way of being.
So that when you do get here, what you will
do is say, this is not enough. You must a
no limit person is never operating from.
deficiency or from lack in their life, they're
never saying, I don't have enough.
You see, you're never going to get enough.
You already are everything, you're everything
that you need. Think of it for just a moment.
Everything that you need to have total bliss
perfection of your life. You already are.
You already have it. You came into this world
with nothing. That's how you're going out.
And the time that you have here, it, what
you have is your uniqueness, your specialness,
and you don't need anything else. Now think
on this. If you don't know how to appreciate
what you have and where you are in your life,
you don't need anything else. Because if you
do get something else, you won't know how
to appreciate that either.
You'll just want more or you'll want it to
be different, or you'll want it to be the
way it used to be. Or you'll want someone
else to be the way you think they should be.
Successful people, or no limit people or self-actualizing
people or inner directed people. However,
you, whatever labels that have been put on
them by great thinkers and philosophers and
therapists and people, uh, that have, uh,
looked at human beings.
These kinds of people are people who always
have enough. There are some people, if you
invite them over and you say, um, you know,
I'd like you to, uh, I'd like you to come
over tonight and I'd, I'd like you to stay
over if you can, instead of having to drive
back. And they'll say, well, can you say,
can you stay?
And I'll say, well, I don't know if I can
stay or not. . Well, you could sleep on the
cot. Oh, no, no. I could never sleep on the
cot. . I don't, I can't sleep on cots. , uh,
I got a sciatica. Don't you know, than I have
a, I have back pain and a, I don't cots. No,
that's out of the question. I couldn't sleep
on a cot. Uh, and what about breakfast?
Well, we don't have any food, but, um, we
have some old grapefruit that are in the,
uh, in the, uh, refrigerator. They have a
few spots on 'em. Oh, no, I could never eat
grapefruit on, on spots. No thanks. I can't
eat grapefruit spots. I just couldn't do that.
You know? Uh, and these are people who, uh,
never have enough.
They are, are not able to be flexible and
to chain. And there are other people. If you
say, would you like to sleep over? Uh, we
got a place in the sewer . Hey, that'd be
great. I can handle that. No problem. I slept
there before. It's all, and all we have is
grapefruit. Oh, I love grapefruit. Well, we
got, there's got spots.
I'm, oh, I really like grapefruit spots. Those
are terrific. I'll, I'll go for those. There
are some people who can handle anything, not
because they're circum. Circumstances are
different. You see, your circumstances have
very little to do with your fulfillment in
life. Very little. It's, it's how you're approaching
your circumstances.
It's your attitude towards your circumstances
that make all the difference in the world
and taking what you are and accepting it.
I gotta show you this. I don't know if the
camera can get this. This is a little, uh,
advertisement that was in the Detroit Free
Press, uh, for, uh, last September. I was
giving a speech at the Unity Church of Today
in Detroit, and it says, uh, Dr.
Wayne Dyer will talk about your inner child
and how to deal effectively with problems
in all relationships. And it was a real nice
ad. You can see that. Then on top of the ad,
in the same. There's another ad , and the
ad says, face it,
right on top of my ad. There's no hiding from
hair loss. And they got a picture of a guy
with a box over his head,
and they have a before and after guy there.
And the after guy looks like he's just found
fulfillment. And it says you can't run and
you can't hide. Hair loss is a problem. And
unless you take action, it will continue.
. Now we've gotta look at this, uh, in terms
of, uh, what I can do with this and how I
can handle this.
See, my daughter helped me with being bald
a long time ago. She said, dad, you're not
really bald. Don't think of yourself that
way. She said, you're just about this much
taller than your hair. That's all . Which
is sort of a nice way to look at it too. I
just sort of outgrew my hair, sort of transcended
my hair, if you will, right?
No limit. People are human beings who take
what they are and accept it and don't tell
themselves that somehow they're deficient
because of anything about themselves.
This is a very crucial, uh, concept for, for
me and for virtually all of us. It's this
idea of taking your life in your own hands
and being the kind of person that you choose
to be, and understanding that everything that
comes your way is an opportunity, is a blessing.
And it wasn't until. I learned how to celebrate
virtually everything that came my way, that
I was able to transcend it.
You see, everything that was given to us by
God, whatever that is, is perfect. No one
can deny. The mountains are perfect and the
rivers are perfect, and the birds are perfect,
and the hippopotamus are perfect, and, and,
and so on. This is just what was given to
us. Everything else that you have on our planet,
that we have on our planet comes about as
a result of thinking, thinking, thought makes
it so, all right.
This microphone comes about as a result of
thinking. Somebody imagines it, somebody then
tells somebody else about, and it's, and it
creates it. The dress that you're wearing,
this shirt that I'm, the shoes that you have,
the stage, these cameras, everything that
you see that wasn't given to us was created
by man as a result of the way that we think,
the way that we think.
So what gets inside of us as a cell comes
about as a result of the way that we choose
to think in our lives. Very important principle
to understand because once you get a hold
of thinking and that it creates everything
that you have in your life, you can change
and make it as absolutely perfect as you want
it to be.
Because thought makes it so creative. Visualization
is what we're talking about here. You, the
imagery or the image that you have of anything
in your life is really like mental behavior.
It's like going out and practicing. If you
go out and practice with a basketball shooting,
uh, free throws over and over again.
That's physical practice. Imagery is mental
practice. It's mental behavior. When you have
an image that you can succeed at some, at
something, when you have an image that you
can do it, rather than that, you can't do
it. When you get into your car and you have
an image that you're going to find a parking
place rather than that, there'll be no place
to park.
So you're not looking for no place to park.
You will start acting on the image that you
have very much like you will start acting
on the practice that you have when you're
shooting baskets or when you're hitting a
forehand or, or working on your soup or anything
else that you're doing. Bucky Fuller, who
I served with on the Hunger Project Advisory
Council for nine years, who died not too long
ago, said that 99% of who you are, you can't
touch, you can't see, you can't smell.
99% of you is untouchable, unsellable, and
visible. It is what Ken Kai has called your,
your conscious awareness. It's your, it's
what looks out behind those eyeballs. What
is that? It isn't. It isn't cells. It's some
kind of conscious awareness that you are.
And make no mistake about it, you've occupied
a whole lot of bodies already.
Now, this is not reincarnation talk, although
I don't know about this reincarnation. People
ask me if I believe in it. I said, well, I
taught in a junior high school in the inner
city of Detroit for four years, and I saw
those dead bodies come to life every day at
three o'clock. . So I believe in reincarnation.
All right,
Now, if what you, if 99% of who you are, you
can't touch and you can't feel, and you can't
smell, then where, what is it? Who is it?
Where are you? What is this thing called your
essence or who you are and where does it go?
Now think of this. You were in a body. I have
a little baby girl who's, uh, 11 months old
and she, and we were all in a body that size.
Well, it's only a body about this big. Got
fingers only this long. , you know, got, uh,
tiny, tiny little parts all over the place.
I mean, she's only this tall now, is that
her? Is that her essence? Because I have other
children who are much older, and I am much
older than that. And I can remember being
three and being in a different body, still
me, still my essence there.
Different body, totally different. Doesn't
even look anything. Like when I was 11 months
old and then I was 13 and had a funny body
at 13 . But still my essence was there in
a whole new body. Hairs growing all over the
place that I didn't understand. All kinds
of things happening to it, you know? Then
hairs falling out of it later on.
You know, looking at those hairs that fall
out and say, what held it in yesterday? You
know, ? No, no. I don't even understand that.
Okay. And so it's like, who I am has been
in many, many bodies already. All right? And
that essence, you see everything on our planet
that is alive, can never die, but can never
die.
Life doesn't die. It just transforms. It just
moves on to new places and new ways of being.
New ways of being. And the way of being that
is the most transcendent of all is this way
that comes from seeing yourself as love and
only having that to give away. Only having
that to give away. Let's say I would stand
up here in front of you and just visualize
for a moment that I have an orange, and I
take this orange and I squeeze it as hard
as I can squeeze it, okay?
What's gonna come out? Juice. What kind of
juice? Orange juice. Apple juice. Any chance?
. Once in a while. Come on now. And then little
mango juice come out of an orange once in
a while. No mistakes, right? Never. No matter
what. Next question. Everybody passes. These
are easy. Okay. Why? When you squeeze an orange
as hard as you can squeeze it, does orange
juice come out?
Because that's not, cuz it's an orange because
that's what's inside, isn't it? On our planet,
when you squeeze something, what comes out
of it is what's inside. Not too difficult.
All right? Does it matter if your mother squeezes
the orange? Does it matter what instrument
she uses? Does it matter if you just had your
period and then you squeeze an orange
Does it matter if your boss squeezes it? How
about if your kids do it? Your kids squeeze
an orange? Does it your kid squeezing on?
Does it matter? Does it matter what time of
day? Suppose they do it at noon. All right?
How about at four in the morning? Does that
matter? Whenever you squeeze an orange, the
only thing you get out is what's inside, right?
No arguments. Same thing works for you. Same
principle works for you. It's a principle
of the universe. All right? Someone squeezes
you. That is someone puts pressure on you.
Someone says things about you that you don't
like. Someone puts, uh, attention on you.
Whatever your boss says, something to you
that you don't like, and out of you comes
anger.
And out of you comes hatred. And out of you
comes fear or out of you comes stress or out
of you comes tension. Why? Is it because of
your boss and the way they squeeze you? Never.
Is it because of your mother? I mean, she
really can be a pain sometimes, right? Is
it because of your children? Now, what comes
out of you always when someone squeezes you
is what's inside.
This is the, the vital principle of being
a no-limit person. It's so crucial to get
this and understand that that. If you have
any hatred in your heart for anyone in this
world or any anger or any fear or any of those
things, it has nothing to do with the rest
of the world. It only has to do with what
you put inside.
Now, how does what gets inside of you get
there? That's the key. How does it get there?
As you think, only as you think you see, there's
no anger in the world. There's no stress in
the world. There's no tension. It's perfect.
We've already established it's perfect place.
It works just fine. It's all flowing the way
it's supposed to flow.
The evidence for it is, it is . That's all
the evidence you need. Just look around you.
Everything out there is a miracle. Everything
including you. There are no mistakes. It's
all perfect and everything that happens to
you in your life, whether it's a trauma, whether
it's a disease, whether it's somebody treating
you in a certain way, there's a lesson in
all of it.
No limit. People understand the lesson in
life and therefore celebrate the lessons.
It's true. And when you get to that point
in your life where you're not cursing, the
things that come your way and blaming the
things that come your way, and particularly
blaming it on somebody else, and you hear
it all the time, she hurt my feelings. How's
that possible? How can anybody hurt your feelings?
Your feelings come from your thoughts. No
one can hurt your feelings without your consent.
No one can make a fool of you without your
consent. No one can embarrass you without
your consent. These are choices that you have
that come from the way that you think. Someone
calls you a name, hey, stupid, and you turn
around.
I didn't even tell anybody I was coming. How
did they know that? All right, . And then
you blame the person who called you a name
instead of saying that's just their opinion.
That's just where they are. That's where they
are on the path. And it's okay. All of you
are in relationships, right? Everybody has
a relationship of some kind or another
in your relationship. You have any problems,
any of you have a relationship and you don't
have any problems. , I'd like you to take
this microphone. I wanna sit down and listen
to you . Everybody in a relationship has problems,
don't they? Right now when you say, I'm in
a relationship, I got problems, therefore,
there's something wrong.
Something's really wrong right? Now. If you're
in a relationship and you have problems and
something is wrong, you gotta call in a consultant,
right? You gotta call in somebody to help
you with the problems. You don't want the
problems to go on. Who are you gonna call
in? You only got yourself, that's all you
got.
You might get a therapist once in a while,
but they got worse problems than you do. . The
only consultant who can help you with your
problems is you. And who is that consultant
that you're calling in? We've already established
that there's something wrong with that person,
right? Something wrong. So now you're gonna
call in a disabled person, , to deal with
your problems in your relationship right?
Now, this is a really sick approach to curing
your problems. You got somebody who says,
we got a problem. You don't talk to me. I
didn't talk to you, and you came home week
last week, and this week I called you and
you didn't call, and I was supposed to call
you, and then you didn't do it. And how can
you do that?
Now, this is the consultant you're calling.
Excuse me, will you come in and help us? Oh,
no, I can help you. Come on. Good . That's
the person you got to deal with your problems
. All right? Now what you can do is you can
change all of that around. You can say I'm
in a relationship. We got problems. That's
right.
There's nothing wrong with that. That's the
way things are. You know, my problem is that
you are different than I am and you think
differently than I do, and you behave differently
than I do. And you smell different than I
do. And you have all of these attitudes over
here that I don't have nothing wrong with
that.
That's the way it is. When two people get
together in a relationship, you don't have
two people becoming one. If you do that, then
what you end up with are two half persons
who wants a half a person in a relationship.
You always are single. Even if you're married
and for you know, and involved in relationship
for, you're still always single.
You're still always you. Your unique, special,
perfect self that is not trying to love, but
who is love, who lives love, who is being
love. The same as if you pray to God and say,
God, will you please help me with my problems
and want God to do it for you? Never have.
You've got to be God. Not be afraid to carry
God around inside of you if you want to get
healed.
You have got to understand that you're not
going to get healed if you are asking someone
else to heal you. And ask any doctor that
you know, any surgeon particularly who's taking
somebody into surgery and ask them which person
has a better chance of living, of surviving,
say, serious surgery. Is it the one who has
a will to live?
Or is it the one who's just given up and the
surgery and the cases are exactly the same?
Alright, but the person who has that will,
which we can't define, you can't go out and
get a bucket full of will and bring it in
there. It's an attitude. It's an approach.
It's a belief, all right? That you can do
something.
And when you have that belief about yourself,
You know, you've got a, so much better, uh,
opportunity to be well in your life. And a
belief is everything. I don't know if you've
ever thought of that. Uh, I watch, uh, a little
girl, five years old, learning how to swim,
and she's holding onto the edge of the pool
and she wants to get over here to the steps
and it's just, uh, five feet or six feet,
and she'll let go and then she'll hold on
again and she'll let go and she'll hold on
again.
And finally there comes a time when she, lets
go and goes for it. Okay. You've all seen,
you've seen this with your children, you've
seen, and what you ask yourself is in the
moment before that, when she was holding on,
and then look at the moment afterwards, does
she have any different skills? What's changed?
Yeah. Yeah. The skills are, she didn't have
any new skills. She didn't learning any skills
in that second. What she has is a belief that
she can do it. And when you believe it, when
you really just believe that you can do it,
that's what allows you to swim. And when you
think about it now, do you know how to swim?
Yeah. So when you dive into the water, you
don't think about that. You just know when
you dive into the water, you can swim. You
don't have any necessary swimming skills or
anything like that. Or when you get on a bicycle,
you get on, you know that you're gonna, unless
you believe you can't, because you've never
gone out there and tried it and worked on
it and done it, told a story of a patient
of yours who had that very problem who said
she didn't know how to ride a bicycle.
Mm, yeah. Gail, who came to me many years
ago, and you know why she said she couldn't
ride a bicycle because her mother wouldn't
let her get on one cop out. Yeah, absolutely.
And she had these beautiful big white teeth
and her, uh, mother had always told her, you
could fall and break your teeth, and I wouldn't
want that to happen to you.
So here she was now in her thirties and, uh,
telling me that she couldn't ride a bike and
she was in therapy. And, um, I said to her,
okay, let's go. She said, go, where are we
going? I said, well, I've got a bicycle downstairs
and I'm gonna, uh, show you how to ride a
bike. I'm gonna have you teach yourself how
to do this.
And she said, look, I didn't come here to
pay you the kind of money that I'm paying
you to have. You teach me how to ride a bicycle.
I came here to find out why I can't. I said,
oh, well, you're gonna need. 30 seconds of
therapy easy. Okay, , the reason you can't
is because you never got yourself on a bicycle.
And until you do, you never will know how.
And you just believe that you can't. Oh, that's
the end of that. There's no more to talk about
that. Now what we have to do is get you to
get out there. And we went downstairs and
I had, it was a woman's bike and I've helped
a lot of people to teach themselves how to
ride a bike.
And what you do when you teach, you help someone
to teach themselves how to ride a bike cuz
you don't teach anybody how to ride a bike,
okay? Uh, is you let them do it all themselves.
You let them hold it, you let them balance
it, you let them move with it. You let them
put the pedal down and, and, and move it themselves.
And you stand back, you say no when you're
ready, you know, and then you move it and
you hold on for a second, and then you put
your foot back down and you, you practice
it and practice and practice that all yourself,
you know, with just someone encouraging you.
And before long, in just a matter of minutes,
when I tell you it was minutes, and this woman
had never been on a bicycle before.
She rode like two blocks on a bicycle. She
couldn't believe that she, she now had a belief.
Being to me means seeing the greatness and
the uniqueness in you and never letting anybody
else convince you to the contrary, when people
ask me, come on, you're always talking about
being up and you're always positive and so
on.
You mean to tell me that you're always that
way? This is, I say, yeah, yeah, I really
am. And it isn't because I'm out there doing
something in an artificial way. It's an authentic
response to my having, having gotten the junk
out of me. And the junk is the way that I
used to think, the way that I used to think.
Think for a moment. If you can visualize right
here, a clock, big clock, and the hands on
the clock go from one to 12. The clock starts
right out here with the minute hand, and it
goes over towards the three, the, uh, our
hand, minute hand. And that's the time in
your life when you are moving away from yourself,
from your true self.
That's the time when you are trying to put
other people down, trying to prove that you're
bigger and better than somebody else, trying
to make yourself right all the time as opposed
to, uh, being with somebody else. It's like
you're moving away and a lot of people spend
a lot of time moving away from their true
self cuz your true self is this little child.
It's this beautiful little child inside of
you that has only love and acceptance for
everything in the world. And no dise, no absence
of ease. You move away towards the three and
then you move down here this way and you're
still moving away from yourself until you
hit the six. The six is the point in your
life symbolically, metaphorically here.
When you are the furthest away from yourself
that you can be, it's the low point in your
life. It's the point where ver many people
break down or many people break down their
relationships or they, they feel full of despair,
they feel full of hatred, whatever it may
be. And a lot of people die then. A lot of
people are put into hospitals then a lot of
people have to really seek out therapy then
and so on.
And when you're at that six, there's another
part of the clock that goes from six to 12
that I think of as, uh, living in the light.
And this is when. And see, this clock hand
never can go back. It can't go back. It can
only go this way. It only goes this way, as
does life. It only goes this way forward in
this period, this place between six and 12.
That's when you start coming back to yourself.
That's when, that's what enlightenment is.
That's what, that's the pathway to enlightenment.
When you send out that stuff that is destroying
you, that is killing you in one way or another,
and you move yourself back over here and eventually
you get yourself all the way back.
This is the light over here. This is the place
where you can't go back. , you'd be tempted,
you might be tempted to steal, you might be
tempted to, to to use anger. You might even
slip a little bit and you catch yourself.
I can, th just not too long ago it was, uh,
we, we, we got a problem with our sprinkler
at, at, uh, in my home.
One of the sprinkler heads is off. And if
you've ever seen that happen, you get a gusher
of going up there. And I've been wanting to
get that thing replaced for the longest time.
And I'm walking out of the bank and there's
a sprinkler head right there, in, in front
of the bank. Now I practically own this bank,
Okay? So I'm gonna go there every day and
I do a lot of business with this bank, and
I'm looking at this sprinkler head and I think,
you know, all I have to do is just unscrew
this thing. I wasn't honor anything. They'll
replace it tomorrow morning. It's, it's 98
cents or whatever. So I actually get down
there and I look and I start turning the sprinkler.
And then I start thinking, do I want this
karma? Do ? You know, do I want the, do I
want a steal? Do I want take, I know it's
only a 99 and if I went into the bank, they'd
probably give me one anyway if I asked them.
And I turn, and then I just turned it back
and I said, if I want a sprinkler head, I'll
go and buy one for myself.
This doesn't belong to me. It was just like
a split second of weakness there or whatever.
But it illustrated to me that I can't go back
there. I could never, and there was a time
in my life when I could have done that. I
can be absolutely frank with that. I could
do that. Uh, I can't go back there anymore.
That's where you start, that's the place to
start. Because when you get all of that out,
when that's all gone and I mean gone, and
it only comes about as a result of the way
that you think. So it's just changing around
your approach to life, the way that you think
in life. When that starts to go away, what
you've become filled up with is what your
natural self is, which is this loving, accepting,
uh, not fighting the universe, but instead
living in it and going with the flow and all
of the kinds of cliches that you've heard
a thousand times.
It is, that's the metaphor there. And you
see every time you try to go back, can't do
it. You can't do it. And the ingredients that
make for a no limit life are five, in my opinion.
The first is quality rather than appearances.
You begin to change your thinking from appearances
and how things look and how other people view
me, okay?
Because every time you find yourself upset
in life about anything that anyone else has
said, what you're really saying is what you
think of me is more important than what I
think of me. All right? So you change from
appearances to what I call quality thinking.
Quality. What is the quality of my life rather
than how does it appear to others?
Now, do you tell yourself that because my
friends don't like me, that that means there's
something wrong with me? No. That, see, that's
what you have to learn, that another person's
opinion is just that. It's their opinion and
that's all it is. Every time you are upset
or your children are upset because of what
somebody else says about them, including their
peers, what you are really saying in that
moment, and this is really important, what
you're saying is, what you think of me is
more important than what I think of myself.
And you must never give anybody that kind
of power and control over you cuz they will
always have it. The funny part about approval,
for those of you who really want it, and re
now I'm here to tell you that I like approval.
I enjoy it. I find it one of the most exciting
things in the world. I like it when people
read my books.
I love it when people applaud. I like it when
people, uh, tell me nice things and all. I
like approval. I'm the first one to admit
it. What I don't do is I don't need approval.
There's a big difference between wanting approval
and needing approval. When you need approval,
it means you become immobilized when you don't
get it.
From making other people's opinions more important.
Now, for those of you who say, yeah, but I
want approval and I need it, and if I don't
get it and so on, then understand this. The
people who get the most approval in life are
the ones who care the least about it, and
the ones who get the least approval are the
ones who are always going after it.
So if you want approval in this paradoxical
way that I'm talking about it, stop needing
it. Stop concerning yourself about, ask yourself
who gets the most approval in life? Think
of the person that gets the most approval,
and you'll see that that person couldn't care
less what other people are thinking.
They're so busy being, they don't have time
to notice what their neighbors are doing.
Arose said this, he said, if you advance confidently
in the direction of your own dreams, an endeavor
to live the life which you have imagined,
you will meet with a success unexpected in
common hours. What that means is that success
is not something that you can get in life.
Success is an inner process. Success is something
that you bring to everything you do in your
life. It isn't something you get out of what
you do. And when you get that and you learn
how to get the junk out and advance confidently
doing what makes the most amount of sense
to you based on your inner signals, and the
one issue of morality, which is you never
interfere with anybody else's right to do
the same.
Each person has their own right to advance
confidently in the direction of their own
dreams. And when you violate that, you're
violating the principle of the universe, the
essence of the universe, which is cooperation
and harmony. Then success will begin to chase
you and it will come into your life and arrive
in your life in amounts that you never dreamt
of before.
That you never dreamt of things will start
happening to you that you would never imagine
before. I'm working on a book right now that's
gonna be called, you'll See It When You Believe
It, and when you start believing in some of
these principles, you'll start seeing things
that you were blind to for so long when you
were back here in the two and the three and
the four and the five when you were moving
away from yourself.
As long as you're moving back towards your
universal essence, your harmony with yourself,
your cooperation with the rest, things will
start happening in ways that you never dreamt
of. Yun called it, uh, synchronicity and we,
it's, it's a term that we use to, to explain
how unexplainable coincidences sort of happen
in our life and how come these things happen.
I'm gonna share a couple of those with you
before we leave. The, the quality versus appearance
in your life means that you get that inner
candle flame working in a way that gives you
quality independent of what other people think
of you. Maslow in defining self-actualizing
no limit, people said they are independent
of the good opinion of other people, of the
good opinion of other people independent of
it.
They're so busy advancing confidently, doing
the things that make sense and bringing success
to changing their baby's diaper and bringing
success to weeding their garden and bringing
it to the job. They bring it on the airplane
so that when they run into somebody who is,
who is rude to them, a stewardist that is
rude, they don't see it as an attack on them,
it's just where they are and they send them
love, help them a little bit.
You know, they're kind when somebody wants
to get in on the freeway and they're, uh,
one old temptation when they were on the one
to the sixth side. Was to say, oh yeah, nobody's
getting in front of me. I'm getting there
first. It's like it's slowed down a little
bit. They don't have all that type A stuff
of having to beat somebody else and having
to defeat somebody.
It is, it's a new way of being. It's a way
of quality where your harmony allows you to
cooperate. And you are a part of what this
whole thing is about. New way of being, quality
rather than appearances. Another new way of
being very important. Living your life on
ethics rather than rules. Ethics rather than
rules.
All these rules, all these ways of having
to do things somebody else dictates to the,
do you know that some of the most immoral
acts in the world have been perpetrated in
the name of the rules? These are the laws.
What do you think Nazi Germany was all about?
Everybody doing all these horrible things
to other people.
I'm only doing my job, was the defense. We
all heard at Nuremberg. I was just doing my
job. If it's an immoral rule, it's immoral
to obey it. And self-actualizing people, as
Maslow tells us, have rules inside of them
that they could never obey, never disobey
ever. And they have to do with ethics, how
you treat people.
How do you think we get to where we are now?
You know who Rosa Parks was? The woman in
the south, the black woman in the South who
said, not today. I'm not going to the back
today. No way. I know what the rules are.
The rules were all over the place. If you
didn't need, if you needed a reminder, there
were signs.
Every place colored in the back, white in
the front. And she said, no, I'm sitting here.
And that made all the difference. Ethics not
rules. When your children start disobeying
rules that need to be disobeyed. Don't be
surprised when I was in the. They had a policy
on Guam where I was stationed, which would
not allow the Guian civilians to shop in the
pxs in the Navy exchanges.
But they did allow all other civilians to
shop in the Navy exchanges and pxs. But if
you were Guamanian, that is, if your skin
was dark and your eyes were shaped a little
different, then you couldn't a clear outright
violation. I was a serviceman. I was in the
Navy, I was a communications cryptographer.
They had a, uh, a newspaper in the Guam Daily
News and it said, an invitation to speak your
mind.
There was a letter writing contest and they
offered $75 to the first prize winner, $75.
This was 1961. That was a fortune to me. That
was a month's pay in the Navy at that time
almost. So I entered the contest and I knew
I would win it. I had already written a novel
at that time, a whole novel I had written
while I was on Guam.
I knew it wasn't gonna be a contest , uh,
I felt sorry for the other people entering
it. I knew I was gonna win this . Unfortunately,
I didn't realize that when you're in the service
and you have an opinion and you don't submit
it to the chain of command, that you can be
court martial for that. So the headlines on
next week's Guam Daily News were US Sailor
a sales policy of discrimination.
Big hot stuff. All right, . And I was called
before a Vice Admiral Commander, Naval Forces
Marias Islands, and threatened with a court
marshal because I had disobeyed the rules
even though the rule was immoral. There are
lots of them like that. And when I went in
and they threatened me with the court marshal,
I told them this was my battle plan.
They didn't have Xerox machines in those days,
so I had to get a lot of carbon paper. I wrote
a letter to the President, John F. Kennedy,
and I wrote a letter to the Secretary of the
Navy and I wrote a letter. I was, my hometown,
was Detroit. I wrote a letter to the Detroit
News and a letter to the Detroit Free Press,
telling them what was happening to me as a
result of just expressing my opinion about
an immoral act that was going on over here
on Guang.
And I showed the naval, uh, uh, vice Admiral,
my letters right there. I said, I've only
sent the one to the President and the Secretary
of the Navy. . These letters go to the newspapers
across the country. There was one there to
the New York Times as well, and the Los Angeles
time, it was, uh, and I just spread them out
before 'em.
I said, if you court marshal me or punish
me in any way for this, then what's gonna
happen is the world is gonna find out about
this policy. And I'm prepared. I'm ready.
I can handle it. And I was 20 years old at
the time, or 21. Not only did I get a blessing
from that, because all things come in blessings
for you.
I got out 90 days early
and they stamped on my record PI because the
president took it up and sent it to the secretary.
Must have. And I never heard from him, but
I, uh, PI on your record means political influence.
And they don't like anybody with political
influence in the military. And as soon as
they saw that, they said, this is somebody
we probably will be, uh, giving a discharge
real soon.
there was no court. There was no court marshal.
And in September of 1962, a brand new policy
was initiated on Guam, which allowed any civilian
to shop in the Navy exchanges. And it came
about as a result of someone saying, these
rules are immoral and therefore it's immoral
to obey them. New ways of being, ethics rather
than rules.
And when your kids want to know why. How come
these rules are so stupid? How come we have
to do this? Encourage them to change them.
My mother always did that. She would have
to help me, uh, get out of the, out of the
messes that I got myself into because I, I
did it in my impetuous youth. I would just,
when they would say to me, what's more important,
your job or school?
I was just honest. , I said to my job. Of
course, that's how I felt in those days. But
what you do put out in the world is exactly
what's coming back to you. And if you find
things coming back to you that you don't like
and don't understand, don't ask yourself why
these things are coming to you. Ask yourself
what you're doing to make them come back to
you.
And when you start putting the responsibility
on yourself, you'll start seeing dramatic
changes. Dramatic changes, a new way of being.
Instead of ethics. Instead of rules, ethics,
a new, another new way of being. Instead of
looking all your life for achievements and
externals, try living your life on knowledge
for the sake of knowledge.
Knowledge instead of achievement for the sake
of knowledge. Being in a, in a context in
which you don't have to collect a lot of merit
badges, you don't have to collect a lot of,
a lot of, uh, awards and other people's, uh,
value judgment. That you go to school or you
go out into the world or you read or whatever.
It's you do because it makes sense to you,
not because of what somebody else is going
to put on a transcript or where you're gonna
appear in a class list. We need to help our
children to understand and value the importance
of knowledge for the sake of knowledge and
doing things that make sense rather than taking
the easy way.
Knowledge rather. Always trying to achieve.
We are in an achievement oriented society,
which tells us that we evaluate and judge
a human being based upon how many achieve
achievements he has. But most of the people
who get caught up in that trap and are always
in this circle of trying to get ahead, trying
to always get ahead, their reward for that
almost always is higher blood pressure ulcers,
early deaths, and even things like cancer,
we're beginning to find out are related to
the kinds of stresses that we have.
And remember, it's a perfect universe. There's
no stress in it. There's only people thinking
stressful thoughts. And when you put that
pressure on yourself to always achieve and
get ahead of the other guy, you miss what
it's really all about. There's nothing wrong
with goals. It's falling in love with them.
That's the problem, . It's not being able
to be flexible and be alter them. If you have
a goal to get here, to get a hundred thousand
dollars in the bank to get to this promotion,
to get two cars in your garage, what? Whatever
it is that your goal is, and you're on your
way to that and you're always working at the
goal, all of this stuff on your way to the
goal is called striving, and that's what you
learn.
Striving. Striving is a very low level place
to be when you get to your goal because all
you've ever known is striving. You will just
always suffer from this disease called more.
You will just upgrade your goal, the $200,000,
four cars and two houses, and another wife
and a younger one and, and all of these kinds
of things.
If you have a goal and you understand that
every step a along the way is a present moment
to enjoy and to live, then the goal won't
become any obsession. I don't have any goals
in my life. People ask me, where are you gonna
be five years from now? What are you gonna
be doing? What's next for you? I just, uh,
I remember what Lincoln said, who to me was
like the greatest person who ever sat in that
White House.
He said, I'd never had a policy. He said,
I just tried to do what made the greatest
amount of sense each and every day of my life
as I sat there as the president of the United
States. . And I think there's, there's something
really significant in that, that you don't
have to get it all planned out and follow
a certain pattern and do it a certain way.
If you just sort of trust your inner instincts
and go with that and live each moment, the
goal stuff will all take care of itself. But
if you're sacrificing and pushing your life
aside and, and, uh, suffering on your way
to trying to get someplace, you'll never get
there. It will always allude you because once
you get there, you'll just have to upgrade
it.
And that's cuz that's all you'll know. Nowness
is that purest form of sanity living in this
moment and enjoying it and all the rest of
it will sort of work its way out. Another
new way of being for me is to think of yourself
in terms of personal authority. Rather than
being an authoritarian personal authority.
A person who has authority never needs to
dominate. Anyone else ever dominating doesn't
become necessary in business. You can have
authority. The people who have the most authority
are the ones who listen the most and the ones
who are the most conscientious about what
do other people have to say? A person in a
relationship who has to dominate somebody
else and has to make the other person submissive
shows that they don't have authority because
they're getting their power, not from within
for themselves, but on the basis of who they
can control.
And that never lasts. That never lasts. The
only thing that lasts is having inner power.
If you will know thyself, that's what Shakespeare
said, know thyself. The more you know yourself,
the more you, the more you become honest with
yourself. Uh, honesty becomes just a way of
life. No, I don't think the world necessarily
does, but you can't run your world.
You can't run your world based upon what the
rest of the people in the world want or don't
want. To me, honesty is like, it's a karma
that goes out into the world, how people treat
you in the world. Is there a karma? How you
react is yours. And what, when you react to
it with dishonesty, that's what you're putting
out into the world.
Dishonesty. And when you put dishonesty out
into the world, that's what's gonna come back
to you. Because what goes out is what comes
back. That all as you so, so shall you reap.
I mean, it's, it's in every great, uh, institution
that there is in the world. What, whether
it's a religion or a philosophy or whatever,
what you put out is what comes back.
Whatever you plant is what you're gonna get
back. And the more that you put out honesty,
just because it's what you are, because you
are being honesty, you're not trying to be
honest, you are just being honesty, then that's
what will come back to you on a regular basis.
And when it doesn't, you'll just see that
as another test for you to pass.
And finally, a fifth way of being that is
new for me, it has become a way of life. It's
called serenity instead of acquisitions. The
more you try to acquire, the more you try
to get, the more you try to collect in your
life and evaluate yourself on the basis of
that, the less serenity you're gonna have.
More is less. It's almost a secret of the
universe. Serenity means inner peace means
that you can, uh, find joy in every moment
that you have in your life instead of always
looking for it. It means that. while you are,
uh, uh, driving along the countryside, , you
know, and seeing, uh, in, instead of saying,
oh, this is, I'm on my way to this point,
that you can open your eyes and see it with
new eyes.
See, see the rolling mountains, see the grass,
see the deer, see the skies. See, you can
just stop wherever you are in this second,
wherever you are, and just look around you
and you can begin to appreciate just your,
and your surroundings and your environment.
Then you can begin to appreciate the people
that are in your life, and even the ones that
are negative and, and you're having the most
difficulty with.
You can practice a new way of being with them,
which is sending them love, sending them flowers,
send them books, send them a tape, send them
something, and just see what kind of reaction
that you get. Super emotional health is just
an attitude. An attitude is everything. I
want to, uh, summarize these new ways of being
and, and give you the most important, uh,
ingredient on the path as we leave.
I said that, uh, it's quality in your life
to be focusing on rather than appearances.
And it's ethics rather than rules and it's
knowledge rather than achievement all the
time. And it's being personally an, an authority
on yourself rather than authoritarian and
trying to be dominat, dominating someone else
or to be dominated.
And serenity, which is the name of my little
girl, my youngest daughter, Serena, um, rather
than acquisitions and accumulations and trying
to prove yourself that way. And when you get
that serenity, which comes from the way that
you think always, then you will replace all
of the other junk that keeps you back here
between six and one on that clock.
And once you pass it, once you get past it,
you'll never ever be able to go back because
the light, living in the light is a way of,
it's a way of being that if you're not there,
you don't get it yet. But once you see it
and once it begins to, and take over your
life, You can never go back. That be that
is your purpose.
It isn't. Your purpose isn't to try to be
loving. Your purpose is to be loved and only
have that to give away. Well, but there's
one other ingredient, and it's really crucial.
Forgiveness is the vital ingredient on the
path of enlightenment. And if you don't know
how to do it, then practice sending out love.
Take the person or the people that you're
having conflict with any place in your life,
send them something. You don't have to even
do it physically. Just send them something
that comes from inside. And what's inside
is how you choose to think. And if you can
make that love and do that. And that is to
me, the test.
Not whether you can love someone when they
smell good, when they do everything that you're
supposed to, but whether you can love someone
who has sent you hate or anguish in your life
and send it back. You don't have to forget.
You don't have to go back, but you gotta get
it outta you because it is blocking you and
holding you back.
And when I said you'll see it, when you believe
it. All my life I had wanted to write fiction,
a parable. Three, four years ago, I decided
to go off to Hawaii, to Maui, to Kop Poly
Beach, and to write. Now the books that had
met the most difference in my life were the
Little Prince Candide Siddhartha, Jonathan
Livings and Seago illusions, Alice through
the looking glass, Gulliver's travels, parables,
teaching parables, stories that can tell a
message.
I went over to Molly and I sat down on the
beach and I'd been talking about writing this,
I'd been talking about doing this, and it
was something that, and I have a little girl
and her name is Sky. S K Y E.
I decided to reverse the letters in her name,
E Y K S, and put an I in there, which symbolizes
the self ICUs. And I just created this parable
of a woman whose name is ICUs, who lives on
another planet. The planet is Uranus, and
it's a duplicate mirror image of earth. Only
Iki can only see things as they are, not as
we would like them to be.
And therefore, people are neurotic on Uranus
because they have to be. She gives the anxiety
attack report, if you will, because anxiety
really does attack over there and tells about
anxiety coming in on the weekends and so on.
Well, my visitor in my parable goes to Uranus,
me tikis. She cannot understand as he describes
Earth, why people would be neurotic by choice
on earth.
Why would anybody be unhappy or depressed
or miserable when they don't have one? Anxiety
doesn't attack and when elevators really don't
scare you and when, if you want a complex
on Uranus or you want to give a complex to
your wife, you go to the store and buy one
and she says, what happened? Well, my husband
gave me a complex, you know, and it's true.
Whereas on earth, if you have a complex, it's
because you've chosen to have one. She can't
figure it out. Okay? So she comes here, observes
our people, and begins to see the secrets
of the universe and gives us these secrets,
talks to the top leaders in our field. And
that was my parable and I wrote it. And she
gives all of these wonderful secrets, some
of which I've been talking about here today.
But what I wanna tell you is that my wife
gave me a license plate, and the license plate
says icu. Okay? It's a vanity plate. And I
was pumping gas on federal highway in Fort
Lauderdale, Florida, and a little man from
Greece came up to me and he said, but means
this F Yas, uh, which is how you say that
in Greek?
And I said, well, that's just a word. It's
my daughter's name spelled backwards. It's
a parable that I wrote. He said, no, he said,
in Greek, that's a word. I said, what could
that word be? He said, it means best wishes
for all. You'll see it when you believe it.
The great big erroneous zone, the cosmic erroneous
zone.
If you get this one, you'll have it and understand
it all. There is no way to happiness. Happiness
is the way we live in a, uh, celebrity obsessed
world, don't we? Look at me. Notice me. The
Dao teaches something completely the opposite.
Listen to the 66 verse of the water again.
The sea stays low, and because the sea stays
low, all of the rivers and all of the streams
empty into it because it stays humble, because
it stays in that place of just allowing everything
to come to you.
He was trying to teach us the important lesson
of, uh, letting what we know is coming come
to us. I practiced this so much more now in
my life than I did at one time. I can remember
years ago I was, uh, I had written a book
called Dione Zones back in the seventies,
and, um, it stayed on the New York Times Bestseller
list for something like 27 months.
And each many weeks it would be number one,
and then it would go down to number three,
and then it would go September two and down
to seven and all of that. And I was doing
the Tonight Show and those days on a regular
basis. And, uh, so many of the other shows,
the Merv Griffin and, uh, Phil Donahue and
Dyna Shore, I became like a regular on the
Dyna Shore.
I was like, you know, hobnobbing with Burt
Lancaster folks and, uh, you know, just, uh,
and um, What you do is you call and, uh, find
out where you appear on the, uh, on the bestseller
list for the following week on Wednesday.
So you call up on Wednesday, not for the Sunday
coming up, but for the following week.
And I called home and my ego was pretty strong
and I was very much into a lot of notice.
Me, I, I really believe that true nobility
is, is not about being better than anyone
else. Now it's, it's about being better than
you used to be. . And I think I'm better than
I used to be. And just about, I mean, I know
that I'm better than I used to be and every
quality or every characteristic that I hold
to be valuable.
Um, but in those days I was into notice me
and I called home and I had trained my wife
to, uh, call the New York Times. She had this
special number that she could call and with
a certain code and she could find out where
I was going to appear on the bestseller list
the following week. So I called her up and
I said, uh, where am I on the bestseller next,
next week, you know, out in California doing
something?
And she said, uh, you're not on the bestseller
list. I said, what are you talking about?
I was number one on the bestseller list last
week. I said, my, even my voice changed when
I said, , what do you mean I'm not on the
bestseller list? She said, you're not on the
bestseller. This, I'm sorry. She said, your
book is on the bestseller
Big distinction there isn't it? Between believing
that this is me and recognizing that, uh,
you can let go a little bit of, of that, of
that listen to, uh, verse 66 of the Do. Why
is the sea King of a hundred streams? Because
it lies below them. Humility gives it its
power. That's a very important principle to
understand and I live.
On the ocean right next to it. It's my front
yard. And always I watch it to learn something
from this thing called the ocean, which is
the most powerful source of life that we have
on the planet. Without it, there's no life
on this planet. And because it stays low.
So what does this have to say to us? Do you
have the capacity to get past that ego need
to always be saying, notice me.
Look how important I am. I mean, there's been
a proliferation of this lately with this celebrity
silly stuff, isn't it? I mean, CNN is doing,
you know, full hour shows on, uh, on silly
little things about what happened to this
particular celebrity or what happened to that
celebrity. And the celebrity's never even
done anything.
And it's, uh, there's all of this talk about,
and all of the new magazines, I mean, and
you look, you go into, through an airport
and you look on the news stand and all the
same photos just with different magazines.
I don't even know what, what the names of
all of them are, but there's like this huge
market now that we have for people to get
into a state of, notice me, notice me, notice
me.
And how much do we train our young people,
particularly in our schools and so on, that
the one who is the star is the one who gets
the most attention, the one who is, uh, the
most important and the most valuable is the
one that has, uh, the most people liking them.
And so on. This constant obsession with needing
to be noticed when in fact what I have found
for myself is the, the happiest moments of
my life are when I can do it low and slow
and not have anybody out there even know what
I'm doing to be able to, I mean, Louise never
would have, uh, advertised the fact.
Of some of the things I talk about with her
generosity, she does it anonymously. It's
almost always done in those ways. No, look
at me, look and notice me, how important I
am, and so on. So much to learn from that
kind of wisdom, from that kind of inner connection
to the dow, the ability and the willingness
to say, to do it anonymously, to say that
you can just get done almost anything that
you want to get done if you don't become obsessed
with taking credit for it.
Remember the movie, the Magnificent Obsession,
the movie made back, I think in the fifties,
and it was really about what was the magnificent
obsession? It was the ability to be able to
give anonymously. What is Alcoholics Anonymous?
It is, everybody stays anonymous. Nobody has
a title. There's not even anybody in charge.
There's nobody, there's no leaders of this.
There's no president, there's no vice president,
there's no organization. There's no, it's
just, here's, here's a group of people who
just want to help other people whose lives
are out of control. So here's a meeting place
and you come and some one day somebody will,
uh, will chair it and then somebody else another
day will chair it.
And one of the things I've found, and when
I attend one of these meetings, um, is that
I, I feel you'll see so many people who are
down trodden, who feel as if their life has
passed them by who look like they don't have
any teeth. They haven't shaved, they're, they're
dirty. They're, um, God in disguise.
Mother Teresa was asked the question about
what she does when she was in Calcutta. And
she said, every day, every day I see Jesus
Christ in all of his distressing disguises,
all of his distressing disguises, that you
can see this source, you can see the dowel,
you can see it when, particularly in those
who are the most obscure, the most, uh, Isolated
from everyone else.
And whenever I go to one of those meetings
and I hear people get up and they tell their
stories, uh, they, I, I, I always, I feel
that, I feel there's so much presence of the
source of God, of spirit, of Lao too, of the,
of the source, of daou, whatever you want
to call it, in one of those meetings than
I've ever felt in any church.
I've, I, I've never felt the presence of it
more. And I encourage you, any of you watching
this right now, go to one of those meetings.
You don't have to be an alcoholic. You don't
have to. I'm not an alcoholic. I don't call
myself an alcoholic. I was never out of control.
I drank, but I wasn't out of control.
And I, uh, but I still go to those meetings.
I have people in my own family that have struggled
with addiction, and I go with them and I sit
there and I listen to those stories, and I
just, I get shivers down my back when I think
about how beautiful it is to be in the presence
of people, all they want to do is help each
other.
There's a movie called, my name is Bill w
James Woods and Jim Garner. James Garner is
in it. And, uh, he, his life just got totally
outta control with addictions, totally outta
control. And then he went to a, uh, uh, he,
he, he, he went to one of these meetings and
he began to realize, and he said, we can,
we can actually take these, uh, these people,
and all we have to do is all we have to do
is love them.
All we have to do is, and he's so excited
about the concept of being able to go out
there and, and offer it. And I keep referring
to Louise because she's such a hero to me.
Um, there was a time back in the eighties
when our president wasn't even able to say
the word aids. Was he, I mean, he come on.
And here was this lady who before this thing
became the worldwide phenomenon that it is,
Was having meetings in her own house, and,
and going and, and bringing these people,
these downtrodden people who had been labeled
outcasts in society and offering them a place
to learn how to love each other and to care
for each other.
This was long before there was any celebrity
sta status associated with trying to end this
horrible crisis that our country has and our
world has, has had. There was, uh, James Wood
so excited about the idea of we can create
a place where we're anonymous. Nobody has
to know anything about us. We don't have to
say our names.
We don't have to say anything. We just have
to come there and we can help each other.
And before that happened, everybody who got
outta control with addictions, particularly
with alcohol, would, uh, would die. There
was no cure. There was no cure. And where
did they find their cure? They found it in
being anonymous.
They found it in being obscure. They found
it in having no organization. They found it
in having no elected representative. They
founded in having no rules. There are no rules.
You just come and we care if you've been one
day or one hour sober, or even if you're drunk,
you come. We care about you, and you are not
that alcohol.
Who you are is this divine soul. In the 36th
verse of the Dowd doted ching, it says, the
gentle outlast, the strong, the obscure outlast
the obvious. Try to become a little more obscure,
a little less interfering, a little less.
Notice me a little less. You know, one of
the specific kinds of things that you can
do is just as you're about when somebody else
is talking, just as you're about to interject
what you've been thinking about for the whole
time, waiting for them to stop talking, just
as to just stop, to bite your tongue and say,
tell me more.
Or That's very interesting. I have never heard
that point of view before. Even if they totally,
completely disagree with everything that you
stand for to be, to be willing to listen,
to be able to stop practice it. I practiced
it when I did these verses of the Dao. I practiced
it every single day while I was working on
that, just staying obscure.
And for me, that's not always so easy because
of just being recognized wherever I go. And
if I saw someone who was about to recognize
me, I would just put my head down. I would
just walk a little bit past them like something
right now, I just want to be anonymous right
now. I want to be obscure. The Dow says storms
always end.
Verse 23, fierce winds don't blow all morning.
A downpour of rain doesn't last all day. Who
does this? Heaven and earth? You're already
connected to everything you want or need.
It will come to you at the exact perfect time.
As the rivers and the streams come to the
ocean at the perfect time and place you gotta
trust, you gotta know it's going to come to
you.
You don't have to chase after it. You can
become a little less obsessed with your ego
and your self importance and who you are and
what you've done. And you can get so much
more done. And you know what? It's the most
peaceful and sweet, delicious way. It's like
the song that Cecilia was singing about the
rose.
There is an energy in the universe. There
is something that is in each and every one
of us, and it's also in the universe. And
you are connected to it in a way that is often,
uh, perceived to be, uh oh, aloof from us.
Because it's invisible, because it's in the
world of what we call spirit the world that
is not material.
And I would like to suggest that you suspend
your disbelief. Allow yourself to know that
you're not a human being here, having a spiritual
experience, but that is the other way around,
that you're a spiritual being, having a human
experience and the quality of your human experience
is really much more dependent upon how you
use this invisible intelligence and how you
connect to this energy.
And once you have an awareness that you can
never be separate from it, that you and it,
and whatever you call it, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if you call it God, if you
call it divine presence, if you call it soul,
if you call it spirit, if you call it consciousness,
if you call it Christ consciousness, you can
call it Buddha consciousness.
You can call it Louise. You can call it Edna.
You can call it Ralph Alan Watts once said
that you can't get wet from the word water.
It isn't the word that allows you to experience
water, and whatever it is that you call it
is something that is distinct from what it
is. When I was walking in here this evening
on these beautiful grounds, I saw some people
looking at the flowers and the different plants
that were growing.
And as they were looking at them, there was
one person who was obviously an expert, a
botanist of some kind, and he was trying to
explain to each one of the people what the
name was, the technical name for each one
of the flowers. And I was watching that and
thinking, it doesn't matter what you call
it, can't you enjoy it?
Look at that thing. It's orange and it just
came out of nowhere. There's something very
profound about enjoying it and, and being
there with it, rather than being obsessed
with labeling it. There was a very famous
Danish theologian. His name was Soran Kard.
He once said that, once you label me, you
negate me.
Once you place a label on me and and put me
into a compartment or a category of some kind,
I must then become what it is that you have
labeled me to be so that we want to be able
to live our lives and to practice principles
of higher awareness without being so consumed
with what I call ordinary human awareness.
And ordinary human awareness is just the recognition
or the belief system that I am a human being.
Maybe I'm having a spiritual experience, I'm
not quite sure, but higher human awareness,
but is sometimes in the east called city awareness.
In the West it's been called higher consciousness
or Christ consciousness.
There's many names for it, but when you get
beyond just knowing yourself as this body
and this personality and this thing that you
inhabit and begin to realize that who you
are is that which was never born and can never
die when you recognize your eternal self.
And that's what this program is really about.
It's really about recognizing the power, the
energy, the capacity to be able to do what
it says in some of the most holy books that
you've ever read, that even the least among
you can do. All that I have done and even
greater things. And that's not just empty
words from holy scriptures. That's a very
powerful lesson that each and everyone has
can practice and live every day.
What I'd like to suggest to you and what this
program is really about is that there are
higher levels of awareness that are available
to us, A level of awareness that allows us
to do things like, and it may sound a bit
strange, but to manage the coincidences of
our lives, to be able to place our attention
on what it is that we would like to create
for ourselves and our lives.
To literally have the power to know that if
I think about it and I keep it there and I
keep that picture firm within me, that there
is an energy, a source, a capacity within
me that is in the universe and that is also
in me, and that I can use this energy, that
I can manage it. There are many ways to get
the things that we want for ourselves and
our lives, but basically it all begins with
how we choose to think.
As you think so shall you be. Seven little
words that I think are perhaps the most important
things that we can learn and master in our
lives. This old proverb notion that I become
what I think about all day long. And once
you know that what you think about is what
expands, you start getting real careful about
what you think about.
You don't allow your thoughts to be on anything
that you don't want or that you wouldn't want
to have manifest or show up for you in your
life. Emerson said, the ancestor to every
action is a thought, and you can look at every
spiritual tradition, whether it's Eastern
or Western, whether it's ancient or modern,
whether it's civilized quote or uncivilized
quote, whether it's tribal, and there is in
all of these persuasions, this idea that inside
each and every one of us in a place that is
not material, in a place that has no dimensions,
in a place that has no boundaries, that in
each and every one of us, we have this power
and we have this intelligence, and you can
never see it.
I've often said that when you die, if you're
gonna die, And five minutes before you're
ready to leave, they weigh your body. And
let's say it weighs, oh, let's pick a good
number, 150 pounds. All right, . And then
life leaves your body and they weigh your
body instantly after you're dead. And it still
weighs 150 pounds so that your body weighs
the same, alive or dead before it begins to
deteriorate.
And if that's the case, then your life, this
thing that leaves your body and your body
still weighs the same is weightless. Your
life is weightless. You can't put a dimension
on it, you can't put a measure on it. Who
you are is that life. And that life is not
in the dimension of material. It's like if
I wanna wiggle my finger, I just have to have
a thought.
And the thought says, I think I'm gonna wiggle
my finger and then I do this. And you say,
well, that's really no big deal. But it really
is a big deal because there's something invisible
in here that says, I'm gonna wiggle my finger.
I've never seen that. I've never been able
to, you can't. You can put that under an x-ray.
You can try to measure that and find out what
it is in there that allows you to say, I'm
gonna wiggle my finger and you can never find
it. It's not in this world, if you will. So
I can do all the scientific studies. And what
I can do when I do these scientific studies
is I can find the command center inside of
me that a lot, and I can go to the brain and
I can point to a specific point.
And scientists can do this and say, there's
the command center, which allows you to have
a thought. I think I'm gonna wiggle my finger.
But there's no computer and there's no scientists,
and there's no technology that can ever allow
us to go inside and say, there's the commander
in the command center.
Can't find it. and that commander in the command
center, that weightlessness is the part of
us that we just don't pay enough attention
to. And what I'd like to suggest here this
evening is that once you start becoming aware
of the power of thought, and if you look around,
just look around you at everything that you
see, it all began with a thought.
We become what we think about. And that is
probably one of the most important principles
in learning to manifest. But in my mind, as
I think about this idea of getting what you
really want and being able to attract it into
your life, what, what, what we have to look
at is basically the obstacles that we have
conditioned ourselves.
And you notice I say that we have conditioned
ourselves because I have never believed that
we need to be putting the responsibility on
someone else. If you're conditioned, it's
because you have allowed yourself to become
that. And if we are condition, if we've conditioned
ourselves to believe certain kinds of things,
and one of the things that we kind of believe
and hang onto and, and live with is this whole
idea that, um, all of the things that happened
to me in my past are what are keeping me from
doing what I'd like to do today.
So we hang on to these things and we fill
ourselves with blame. You say, I'm the middle
child. I'm the youngest child. I'm the oldest
child. You know, I'm an only child. Any one
of those is a great excuse. You know, if you're
the youngest child, you can say, well, you
know, I never, how could I be making decisions
for myself and be a full, fully a fully functioning
person today when I always had somebody else
telling me what to do my whole life?
How could I think for myself, if you're the
oldest child, you can simply say to yourself,
well, how could I be expected to think for
myself? I always had to think for somebody
else. I was always doing it for somebody else.
And that leaves the middle child. You know
the classic identity crisis. Oh, poor me.
My mother didn't even know my name,
She was always calling me by this one's name
or that one's name . So I don't know where
I fit in. So that take care of everybody except
the only child. And of course the only child.
Well, your parents looked at you and said,
we won't be doing that again. , you have to
live with that. I don't, huh? So everybody
with their birth order or with their mother,
like their sister better or that we had enough,
or we didn't have enough, or we had too much,
or we lived in the north, we lived in the
south.
I'm too tall, I'm too short. I've got too
much hair. I don't have enough hair. It's
falling out, it's not falling out. Whatever
it is, we all have these excuses and I call
all of these things that we hang onto and
use to keep ourselves from reaching these
higher places in our lives. The wake, I call
it the wake, and the wake is uh, comes from
a story that I heard Alan Watts tell one time,
and it was a very powerful story.
He said, your life is like a boat, and it's
heading up the river at say, 40 knots. All
right? And as it's going, you are somehow
able to metaphorically stand on the stern,
the back of the boat, and look down into the
water. Now there goes your life in this direction,
and you're standing here and you're looking
down into the water, and you ask yourself
these three questions.
The first question, what is the wake? What
is it? What is this thing that you see? And
the answer, the wake is the trail that is
left behind. That's what it is. Nothing more,
nothing less. It's the trail that is left
behind. Second question to ask yourself in
this little metaphor, what's driving the boat?
What's making this thing go in this direction?
The answer, the present moment, energy. that's
being generated by the engine and nothing
more. That's the only thing that's making
the boat go in this direction and in this
little scene. This means it's the present
moment, thoughts that I have and how I am
using them that is making my life go in this
direction.
And nothing more. Because the third question
is the most important and powerful question,
and I've ever, ever since I heard it, I've
always thought about this. Whenever I have
a tendency to look back here and blame something,
is it possible for the wake to drive the boat?
That is, can a trail that is left behind,
make a boat, go in this direction? And of
course the answer to that is no. It can't.
It's just a trail that is left behind. And
in that trail, there are an enormous number
of things and every one of us has a wake and
we have a whole lot of stuff in it.
And one of the problems that we have is that
we have a tendency to look at the wake and
all of the stuff that's in it to explain why
it is my life isn't working the way I would
like it to work. So that, um, you can take
a look at the experiences of your life. I
look at the experiences of my life and the
experiences of my life.
I spent some years in a, a series of foster
homes. People have said to me, Ugh, living
in a foster home, that must have been terrible.
I said, no, it wasn't terrible at all. When
you're six years old, you don't wake up every
day and say, oh my God, I'm living in a foster
home. Isn't this awful? Poor me? How come
me and nobody else?
You don't do that. You don't do that till
you. And when you're 40 and your life isn't
working and you're bankrupt and you're a drug
addict and, and, and you're falling, your
relationships are all falling apart and your
family's leaving you, and you say, why is
this happening to you? You said, what do you
expect from me?
I had to live in a foster home. My mother
liked my sister better. We were to this, we
were to. And so it's like we take a look at
all of these things in our way. And I'm not
saying here that you shouldn't be in touch
with your past and all of the things that
are back there, but to use it as excuses for
why you can't get where you'd like to get
today is something that you, if you do, that
you will never get to.
This place that I'm talking about in this
program, which is this place that I call higher
awareness, way beyond ordinary human awareness,
one of the most powerful lessons that you
can ever learn. I had to learn as a young
man. My own father was a man who, uh, walked
away. He left, he left home when I was just
a baby.
Left my mother who's sitting right here, 107
years old. Is that what you, no, you're not
107 , 82 years old Owen. And with three little
boys and all I had ever heard when he walked
out about this person that my older brothers
told me about. And that, uh, when my mother
got her family back together again when I
was nine years old and, and did all that she
could to, uh, to make a family again with
all the hardships, this was a man who never
made a phone call, who never sent a penny,
who spent some time in prison who was an alcoholic,
who died of cirrhosis of the liver at the
age of 49, and was buried in a popper's grave
in Biloxi, Mississippi.
And it wasn't until I went to his grave and
was able to stand there. And I used to dream
about this man and have this more enormous
hatred for this person whom I had never seen,
just based upon what he had done to my own
mother and to my brothers and so on, and all
of the stories that I had heard and all the
research that I had done.
And I ended up at his grave, 10 years after
he had died, when I finally found out that
he was dead. It was on the 27th of August.
It was 1974. And what I did transformed my
life. What I did is I believe I was sent there
by God or whatever you want to call that divine
spirit, the divine presence. And my life at
that time wasn't working.
I was overweight. My relationships weren't
working, my writing wasn't working. There
were a lot of things that weren't going well
for me in my life at that time. Not badly,
but they weren't going at the level that I
knew I was capable of getting to because I
was filled with this hatred, this anger, this
bitterness.
And so what I did is I stood there on his
grave on this little marker in the ground,
and I said, from now on, I send you love.
I forgive you. Mark Twain said that forgiveness
is the fragrance that the violet sheds on
the heel that has crushed it. And once I let
go of that anger and that hatred and all of
my attachment to the bonding that I had done
with these wounds and let go of that and cleared
that out of my life, my writing began to take
place at a much higher level.
In fact, I wrote erroneous zones in very,
very short time. After that, I began to get
myself back in shape. I began to eat better.
I began exercising, keeping my uh, got my
weight down and the people that were supposed
to come into my life, like my beautiful wife
who sits here with me this evening, and all
of our children, some of whom are here this
evening,
All of it was allowed to flow when I released
that, that energy of negativity and blame
and hatred, they say that you never die from
a snake bite. It isn't the bite, and you can't
be un bitten. It's in the wake. What kills
you is the venom that continues to pour through
you long after the bite has taken place.
And that's something we have control over
and we can't change. And I'd like to suggest
that what happens is that many of us bond
ourselves to these wounds of our past. If
I were to cut my hand, just cut it and watch
it, my nature says, flows up the wound, and
I just have to watch it. And there's no doctor
out there, there's no medicine out there that's
gonna heal that wound.
There's something, there's a healing stream
that I am connected to that will allow that
wound to heal. So my nature says, close up
the wounds. Don't bond to them. Don't hang
on to them, close 'em up. But supposing I
say to myself, oh no, you don't. There's no
way I'm gonna let you close up. . You see
if I can keep you open and I can go to you
and say, look at this.
Say what happened? Well, look at this cut.
I've got, oh, you poor thing. Look at that.
It seems to be getting worse. It's getting
infected. . Isn't that terrible? And if you
practice this kind of a mentality when your
nature says close up the wound, but you keep
it open before long, you lose your hand . And
after that, you'll lose your arm and the whole
organism will be destroyed if you don't let
your nature take over.
And your nature also says, close up the wounds
of your past. Close them up. And oftentimes
we ignore our nature. I had a great teacher
that came into my life through his writing.
His name was Nisar Gata. Maharaj lived in
India up until the mid 1980s. And he wrote
something called I Am that, which was very
powerful and influential in my life.
And one of the things that he talked about
when he was asked the question, what's the
difference between say a saint or a highly
functioning human being, a spiritual master,
a spiritual teacher, and the rest of us, is
that they have unconditional love in them
and you don't. Or we don't. And he said, no.
He said, saints have unconditional love in
them and so do you.
He said, the difference between ordinary human
awareness and higher awareness people is that
they have nothing else inside of them. That's
all they have. And it's almost like we have
to learn how to get that in ourselves to be
able to, well, I always like to use a metaphor
of an orange. I love the orange.
Perhaps living in Florida is why. But an orange
is a simple metaphor. You take this orange
and you squeeze it as hard as you can squeeze
it, and you ask yourself what will come out
and what comes out When you squeeze an orange,
orange juice, never, no matter how many times
you squeeze it, will apple juice come out.
There's no mistakes. You'll never get grapefruit
juice out of this thing ever. The only thing
you'll ever get out of it is orange juice.
And the next question is, why? Why wouldn't
you squeeze an orange as hard as you can squeeze
it? Does orange juice come out? And I asked
that question up in Toronto one time, this
little girl sitting right in the front row,
she said, that's dumb
It's a, she said, that's what's inside. It
has to come out. I said, well, that's the
answer. You are really smart. And she's smiled
and she thought that was great. But that's
the truth. The reason that orange juice comes
out when you squeezes is because that's what's
inside. Now. You extend the metaphor and someone
squeezes you.
That is someone says something about you that
you don't like. Someone behaves towards you
in a way that you find offensive. Somebody
does something or says something to you that
you feel hurt by and out of you comes anger,
hatred, bitterness, tension, fear, anxiety,
stress, and immediately you say, the reason
that comes out of me is because of how he
said it or the way that she said that, or
because they did that.
But the truth is, the reality is that what
comes out is what's inside. And if you don't
like what's inside, you can change it. Now,
if you ask me, how does orange juice get inside
of an orange? I would say, I don't know. I
can't figure it out. That's a mystery to me.
I just enjoy the oranges of my life and give
God the credit for that.
A lot of people think that other things make
them the way they are. They will blame their
past. They'll blame their parents. They'll
blame the economy. They'll blame the Aya Toola.
They'll blame somebody for things that are
going wrong in their life. And one of the
favorite things that we have to blame for
why I'm upset at a particular moment is something
called traffic.
Traffic made me upset, and I've always reminded
myself when I'm in a jam or when I'm on the
freeway and I'm trying to get someplace, the
traffic doesn't care. That you have within
you the opportunity in this moment to really
work on these things that are perhaps debilitating
or or creating anxiety or stress in your life,
that these are tests, these are opportunities
for you.
Traffic doesn't care. Your anger is your choice,
and you can always choose to be the be happy,
angry, depressed, miserable, upset, or you
can choose to be fulfilled and do something
positive. In this moment, it's always up to
you. I'd like to give you what I think of
as the great spiritual teachings of many various.
Persuasions. There's a story that summarizes
it. It's the story of what I call the four
philanthropists in a village. The conquerors
had come through and they had taken all of
the men, or many of the men who were warriors
at the time, and they had placed them into
this prisoner of war camp right in the village.
And many of the villagers knew that their
compatriots were imprisoned. And the first
philanthropist was a person who had great
wealth, and he went to the people who had
the prison and were in charge of it. And he
said to them, I understand the men are not
able to have fresh water and cold water. I
would like to donate all of my earnings and
everything that I have to purifying the water
for them and making sure that all of them
will not be sick.
And he was granted that, and he felt like
he had fulfilled his destiny, that he had
done what he was here for. The second philanthropist
discovered that the men were sleeping on rocks
and that they were cold at night. They didn't
have blankets. And he took all of his funds
and he said to them, I would like to provide
bedding and blankets for the people so that
they will be comfortable when they sleep at
night.
And he was granted that, right? And he donated
his money for this purpose. And again, he
felt that he was fulfilling his destiny. The
third philanthropist discovered that the food
that they were eating was inadequate. That
they were just given, uh, beans and, and uh,
and water and some bread. And so he said,
I own a farm and I'd like to grow all of my
food, and I'd like to take this food to all
of these prisoners.
And he was granted that, right? And all three
of these great philanthropists in the village
felt that they had really completed their
mission for why they were here. But the fourth
philanthropist was a saint. He was living
not at ordinary human awareness, but at higher
consciousness levels. And he went and he found
out where the keys were, and he went to the
prison at night and he released all of the
prisoners.
And this little metaphorical story really
tells us that when we are living at ordinary
human awareness, there's nothing wrong with
those who are out there who can help us to
suffer in comfort. All right? And many of
us have learned to do that and accept that
and say, all right, as long as I'm comfortable,
even if I'm suffering, it's okay.
But there are those who have keys, and those
keys can open the prisons. One of the great
teachers in my life was Carlos Castaneda and
Castaneda talked about his teacher who was,
what they call inaugural a, an a Native American
term that, uh, refers to, uh, all that is
knowable. And he, his teacher told him that
your life is like being born into a, uh, a
room, a mansion, if you will, that has a thousand
rooms, but you're born into one room.
And this one room is called daily human awareness.
And the only way you can get in is through
conception and birth you're in. And the only
way you can get out we are taught is to die.
So we spend our lives in this mansion in one
room. Even those, there's 999 other rooms.
We don't know how to get out into those rooms
unless we die.
So we wait to die. And what his teacher told
him is, I can teach you how to get out of
the room of daily awareness and into the other
999 rooms. And if you stay with me and learn
all that, I have to give you, I can teach
you how to get out of the house altogether
without having to die. And what we have to
do in order to get to that place where we
can take the keys and unlock the self-imposed
prisons or the prisons that we have given
ourselves on the basis of what we have come
to believe is our limitations.
What we can and can't do, we have to let go
of that. And I call it rewriting our agreement
with reality. We literally have to make a,
a whole new contract with what it is that
I perceive to be what is possible for me.
And in order to do that, we have to shift
out of the things that we have come to believe
in.
And everything that you came to this program
watching tonight, that you believe in was
handed to you by someone else outside of you,
was handed to you by the experiences or testimony
of someone in the past. And because it comes
from outside of you, there is still an element
of doubt. And this element of doubt isn't
bad, but it keeps you from reaching higher
levels because what you think about is what
expands.
And if you're thinking doubt, then doubt is
what expands. William Blake said, if the sun
and moon should ever doubt, they would immediately
go out. So how do we get past what we believe
in or what has been handed to us and still
honor it and be grateful for all of the teachers
and all of the people who have come before
us?
So what we have to learn to do is let go of
that tribal consciousness and shift to what
I call unknowing. Now, there's a big difference
between what you believe and what you know.
Everything that you know is something that
you have made conscious contact with. Conscious
contact. So there's nobody out there watching.
There's nobody in this world who knows how
to swim, who learned it by somebody else.
Telling them that you can swim or by watching
Mark Spitz go through the water , or by, uh,
observing other people doing it. You may remove
some of the doubt, but you will never know
how to swim until you get in the water and
bleb around a few times and then do it.
And then you'll have a knowing. And that knowing
is something that you'll never lose. Just
like riding a bicycle or dancing the Macarena
or making a, a, a lemon meringue pie or anything
that you know how to do, it's because you've
made conscious contact. And I'd like to suggest
that there's a big difference between knowing
about a divine presence, knowing about a sacred
awareness, knowing about God, and knowing
God.
There's a big difference, just like there's
a big difference between knowing about the
possibility of being able to heal myself of
something that is bothering me, perhaps a
disease process. I perhaps may believe that
it's possible because I've read other people
and I've heard others say it, and I've read
the testimony and I've listened to the tapes
and I've gone to the seminars.
But until you have made conscious contact
with it, you'll never know it. And I'd like
to suggest there are, there's a wonderful
poem I'd like to share this poem with you.
It's, uh, written by a wonderful woman. Her
name is Valerie Cox, and she lives up in Seattle,
and she's written quite a bit of poetry.
This particular poem really speaks to me,
to the difference between what you know and
what you believe in. Immerse yourself in this,
in these words. A woman was waiting at an
airport one night with several long hours.
Before her flight, she hunted for a book in
the airport shop, bought a bag of cookies
and found a place to drop.
She was engrossed in her book, but happened
to see that the man beside her as bold as
could be grabbed a cookie or two from the
bag between which she tried to ignore To avoid
a scene, she munched cookies and watched the
clock as this gutsy cookie thief diminished
her stock. She was getting more irritated
as the minutes ticked by thinking, if I wasn't
so nice, I'd blacken his eye with each cookie
she took.
He took one too, and when only one was left,
she wondered what he'd do with a smile on
his face and a nervous laugh. He took the
last cookie and broke it in half. , he offered
her half. As he ate the other, she snatched
it from him and thought, oh brother, this
guy has some nerve, and he's also rude. Why?
He didn't even show any gratitude.
She had never known when she had been so gall
and side with relief. When her flight was
called, she gathered her belongings and headed
to the gate, refusing to look back at the
thieving in great. She boarded the plane and
sank in her seat, then sought her book, which
was almost complete. As she reached in her
baggage, she gasped, was surprised.
There was her bag of cookies in front of her
eyes. . I love that. I love that. If mine
are here, she moaned with despair. Then the
others were his, and he tried to share too
late to apologize. She realized with grief
that she was the rude one. The integrate the
thief, , the cookie thief, and all of us in
some ways are cookie thieves.
I have eight beautiful children, our youngest
little girls, eight years old. One of the
things that you do when you become enlightened
and become a guru, Like me, , that'll be the
day is when we place something that is important
to know where it is. We practice mindfulness
so that we never misplace anything.
So obviously having reached this exalted level
of awareness in my home with my eight children,
I never misplaced anything. So I place my
keys right here in a certain spot, but my
little girl has this wonderful habit of taking
my keys and hiding them on Daddy in the morning
so that she can watch me flip out as I look
for the keys.
And I'll say, Sage, how many times has daddy
told you Don't hide my keys in the Mor Daddy,
you told me not to do it. I don't hide your
keys anymore. Come on. Where'd you put my
keys? The last time they were in your dollhouse?
Where did you put it? Daddy? You told me not
to do it. And then of course, my 12 year old
daughter, Serena loves to just assume this
stance, , and she's watching me raise my voice.
She'll say, I wonder what all those people
would think of Mr. Positive if they could
see him right now. Get lots of reminders,
. So I give up, I say, look, when I come back
out here, I want those keys here. And I go
back and I get my clothes on and I reach in
my back pocket, and they are my keys, right?
Where I had left them the night before in
my pocket.
And there's a fine line I think, between being
a guru and being a jerk. All right. , and
I probably crossed that line more times than
I should be admitting here on television,
but this idea of being a cookie thief and
creating a knowing, a knowing is something
I did a benefit, uh, along with my wife a
couple of, uh, years ago with a man, uh, on
Maui, uh, whose name is Michael Koff, who
had been, uh, injured, uh, in a.
And an accident. He, he's a, a quadriplegic
or a paraplegic. And at that meeting when
it was over, there was a, a man who lived
on another one of the islands who was known
as a kahuna, a healer, an ancient healer from
Polynesia. And he was introduced to me and
he said, that was a nice talk and so on. And
I said, um, how do you get to be a kahuna?
You know, do, do you take Kahuna 1 0 1? I
mean, uh, what courses do you take? What,
how does this work out? And he said, no. He
said, uh, kahunas are raised to have no doubt,
to have no doubt, to have a knowing. And he
said, when a, when a knowing confronts a belief
in a disease process, the knowing will always
triumph.
And that knowing is something in which you
say you are healed and healing takes place.
One of the great stories of knowing is, again,
with our little girl Sage, who, uh, we were,
uh, spending the summer, uh, in, in our summer
home, and we went to visit, uh, this, uh,
dermatologist. And Sage has had this thing
called flat warts for the last, uh, well since
she was two and a half years old, from two
and a half until seven, which is over four
years.
She had these flat warts. And not only did
she have them around her face, around her,
uh, mouth and around her nose, but they were
getting worse. They were moving up and they
were getting up around her eyes and so on.
And I would notice that, that they were getting
progressively worse, even though all of the
places that we had taken her had said they
will go away, she'll outgrow them.
But it didn't seem to be that way. And they
always said it would be a few months. Well,
years had gone by and she still hadn't. So
we were over at my friends, uh, this dermatologist
on, uh, in KeHE. And he, um, he, I said, uh,
Kenny, as long as we're here, would you mind
taking a look at, uh, at Sage, my wife was
there and he took these big white light and
he put it in her face and he said, uh, you've
got flat works.
she hates that term. . She never wanted to
call them flat ward. She calls them her bumps.
All right? She just called them her bumps.
So, um, he said to her, but the good news
is that when you get married, you won't have
them . Well, she's seven and a half going,
oh, who is this dork you've got me talking
to now?
And then he said to her something, he said,
you know, we can't burn them off and there's
no medicine that we can give them. But he
did say something to the effect that the ability
to rid yourself of these things is within
yourself. And that if you can call upon that
healing capacity in you and begin to talk
to these bumps in a way in which you ask them
to leave, that you have a much greater chance
of getting rid of them faster than anything
that I could give you.
And we certainly can't burn them off because
we might sky your pretty face. And that's
basically the message that he gave us. I'm
paraphrasing it. So we went back that night
to where we were staying, and there was a
whole bunch of kids there, as there always
are when uh, when we're staying. And all of
their friends were there.
And we walked into the bedroom and it was
late at night, and over in the corner in a,
uh, on her air mattress was sage. And she
had the blankets pulled up over her head and
she had a flashlight underneath the blankets.
And I went over and I lifted up the blanket.
I said, honey, is, is everything all right?
She said, shh. I'm talking to my bumps . And
I left the moon. I came into my wife in the
other bedroom and I said, honey, you're not
gonna believe this. But Sage is in there talking
to her bumps. Isn't that great? The next night
we did the same thing. That was the second
night. The third night, the same thing.
Now that was Thur on Friday. This happened
on Monday. On Friday, as God is my witness,
on television, , every single one of those
bumps was gone and has never reappeared since.
Unknowing. You see, there is a stream of healing
that is. Something that we can plug into.
It's very much like electricity. People say,
well, in ancient Greece there was no electricity.
There was electricity. We just didn't plug
into it. That's all. And there's a stream
of healing. And when we go into that stream
of healing with a knowing, we go to a higher
level within ourselves. And we don't allow
any doubt in basically in every single one
of us, every human being out there. There
are two of us, there's two people.
The first person in each, uh, person is called
the ego, or I call it the ego, E g o Earth
Guide Only. Alright? This is the part of us
that says, who I am is separate from you,
separate from God, separate from my environment,
and therefore I'm in competition with. And
my value is based upon how much I get, how
much my stuff is worth, how much better looking
I might be, or how much more, uh, attractive
I might be, how much more money I might have,
the value of my possessions and so on.
What is mine? So it's not mystical awareness,
which says I am connected. It is that individual
lower level of awareness, which says my ego,
this is mine. Also, in each and every one
of us, there's another person, and this other
person is called what I call the sacred self
or the higher self. And this sacred or higher
self really doesn't care how much you get.
It doesn't care who you're better than. It
doesn't care how much stuff you have. It's
not interested in any of that. The problem
is that we very seldom listen to it. We pay
very little attention to it. This hire or
sacred part of us wants only one thing. It
wants us to be at peace. At peace. Whatever
choice you make in every interaction you have.
Make the choice to be at peace, your sacred
or higher self says, whereas your ego says,
oh, no, no, no, no. It's much more important
to be right. And so we find people in relationships
struggling, struggling a lot. And one of the
things that they struggle about is who's right
and who's wrong. Most of the fights that you
have in your relationships, really basically
when you, it's oftentimes you forget the details,
but it's basically about who's right and who's
wrong.
So that if you wanna have your higher or your
sacred part of you ruling in your life, I
suggest this to you, practice being kind rather
than right. When you have the choice, and
you have the choice in your relationships
with your spouse and your ex-spouse, with
your parents, with your grandparents, with
your in-laws, with strangers on the freeway,
with flight attendants, with waiters, with
whomever you interact, if you can just subdue
this ego part of you, which says, it's important
for me to be right, which will introduce you
to stress and anxiety and fear and so much
of the stuff that I talked about earlier.
And instead say, how can I suspend this part
of me and allow the, allow the part of me
that wants to be at peace, that wants to be
happy, that wants to be fulfilled. And if
I said to you, I'm gonna give you a magic
wand, and with this magic wand, I'm going
to allow you to just wave it and get anything
that you want, whatever you want, you can
have this, you can have this car, you can
have this, these, uh, nice clothes over here.
You can have this home. Whatever it's, or
I said to you in lieu of that, I'm gonna give
you another wand and you can wave this. And
for every moment, for the rest of your life,
you'll be at peace. Whatever comes along,
you'll be able to choose peace. And basically
we know that we're only here for a very short
time.
And being able to choose peace, which is what
the sacred part of you begs you, the higher
self. Once you get that, you begin to shift
away and you stop telling yourself that the
people who are close to me in relationship
with me are the people who don't belong there.
I remember my wife and I, we often talk about
this and we, we, we've been together a long
time.
We've had many children together, and we have
a very wonderful, loving relationship. Thank
you, . But we'd often, and one time I said
to her, or she said to me, you know, we love
each other, but this doesn't sound like love.
It does sometimes the way we talk to each
other doesn't sound like love. Let's practice.
Let's practice with each other being kind
rather than being right. And it was transformative
that, that when we had that walk that, and
doing that with your children and doing that
with a waiter, I mean a waiter who comes to
you and is like, you know, hassled and frazzled
and has been busy and all of that, and your
ego says, wait a minute.
I'm here and I'm important and I have a right
to be served and I have a right to be served.
Now that's the ego part of you. If this, if
you can suspend that and say, you know, you
are a lucky man tonight. You got somebody
who's dealing from his sacred self , and I
understand, and you take your time and you
come to me and you bring it at your convenience
whenever you can.
I'm willing to, I'm willing to suspend my,
and you know what? You'll get served so fast,
, and with such gratitude just for being kind
if you practice it. Every single one of us
are in relationship, whether it's with our
husbands and wives, with our ex-husbands and
wives, with our children, our grandchildren.
Whether it's with people we drive along the
freeway next to, whether it's with waiters
and waitresses or baggage handlers or flight
attendants or, uh, people that we are in line
to get into the movie. We're all in relationships
and we interact with each other all the. and
probably the best lesson that I've ever learned
in my life about how to be in a relationship
in a way which is powerful and happy and fulfilling,
is to remember this sentence.
When you have a choice and you always do to
be right or to be kind, start picking kind.
The ego part of us wants to be right. How
dare you not serve me as fast as I think I
deserve to be served? How dare you say something
to me and immediately we wanna make that other
person wrong and make ourselves right, but
there's a part of each one of us that wants
to be happy, wants to be at peace.
And that part of us says, it doesn't matter
whether you're right. It doesn't matter about
your ego. All you want is to be at peace.
So pick kind this kind of an attitude. If
we had more of this, not only in our own personal
lives, would we improve virtually every relationship
we have with all of the people closest to
us and all of the strangers we interact with,
but on our planet as well.
We would begin to understand the wisdom that
on a round planet there's no choosing upsides,
that we're all one, we're all breathing the
same air, we're all drinking the same water,
we're all being warmed by the same sun. And
as they say, as the Native Americans used
to say, no tree has branches so foolish as
to fight among themselves.
It applies in your relationships and it applies
as a people as well. I've often said that
in any relationship in which two people agree
on everything, one of them is unnecessary
. So it isn't about getting somebody who's
just like you. In fact, your soulmate is the
person that you have a lot of difficulty with.
Your soul mate's, the person you can't get
rid of, they just keep showing up. You, you,
you say this, they say that, and there they
are, they're back again, and they never go
away. They keep showing up in your life. And
everybody has these people. These are our
greatest teachers because anybody in your
life who can push a button and send you into
a frenzy is the person who's your greatest
teacher.
You know why? Because they teach you that
you haven't mastered yourself at this moment.
You don't know how to choose peace. And of
course, in miracles, there's a wonderful line.
It says, I can choose peace rather than this.
Whatever it is, I can choose peace. My soulmate,
my wife is one of my soulmates. I mean, she
knows how to push those buttons.
She's really good at it, and she's one of
my greatest teachers. I remember saying to
her one time, honey, do you love me for who
I am or for what I've been able to do for
you? I just wanna, she said that you call
yourself a spiritual person. I can't believe
you would even ask a question like that. She
said, I don't love you for what you can buy
for me, or what success that you've had or
where you are on any bestseller list.
I love you for who you are, and I would always
love you. I said, well, I was just asking.
I said, what if I was just Joe six pack, you
know, and I was just bringing home, you know,
a, a, a meager salary and so on. She said,
I will always love you for who you are. She
said, I would miss you
but I would always love you, . She knows she's
got that, and all of us have soulmates. My
daughter, Serena, who's uh, just turned 13,
my teeny bupp, she came home from school one
day. She said, there's a rumor in our school
she saw somebody had seen me on television,
that you actually wrote a book about how to
raise children.
Tell me it isn't true,
I said, honey, you can come and hear me speak.
Would you like to come and hear me speak?
I said, people actually pay to hear me speak.
She said, why ? I mean, she's, she's got that,
all right. She's. But her soulmate is her
sister Summer, who is now almost 15. But when
Serena was 12 and summer was 14, my wife was
away working on a book of hers, and I was
taking care of everything at home while she
was working on her book about a spiritual
approach to childbirth and infancy care.
And she's as qualified as anybody to write
about that, I can tell you. And I was making
breakfast, I was making waffles for them in
the morning at the toaster. And, uh, , she
mixes all this stuff up. It's a lot easier
to just put 'em in. And summer and Serena
were sitting at the back table in the kitchen,
and I heard summer say to Serena, out of nowhere,
about six 30 in the morning, if you didn't
have any feet, would you wear shoes,
And I turned around. I said, where is this
going? . And so, and Serena went, that's ridiculous.
What do you mean if I didn't have any feet,
would I wear shoes? She said, of course not.
And Summer said to her, then why are you wearing
that bra
Everybody's got a soulmate. stormed out of
the room, and it was a . But it isn't the
people who agree with us. It isn't the people
who tell us the right thing. It isn't the
people who always, uh, find us, you know,
just perfectly smelling good and so on. There
is an element of understanding that everybody
who shows up in our life has something to
teach us.
Many people have said to me that they have
observed in my writing and in my teaching
over the years that I have, um, changed, I've
evolved, if you will, that when I first wrote
Erroneous Zones and Pulling Your Own Strings
and books like this, that I was really talking
about something much different than I'm talking
about today, which is spirituality, higher
awareness, higher consciousness.
And it's true because one of the great teachers
again in my life was Carl Yum. And in Modern
Man in Search of a Soul, he said that there
are archetypes, there are stages that we go
through when we reach adulthood. He said,
those stages. work like this. He said it starts
out with the athlete when you reach adulthood.
And he called it the athlete, not as a putdown
of athletes, but as the time in our adult
life, when our primary emphasis is on our
body, what it can do, how strong it is, how
fast it can run, how much it can lift, how
beautiful it is, and so on. And we believe
that we are a body, if you will, perhaps with
a soul.
He said the second stage is what he called
the stage of the warrior. And this is the
time in our adult life when we take ourselves
out of our physical inv, uh, self, if you
will. And we take this body out into the world
and we do what warriors do, which we attempt
to conquer. We attempt to defeat. We attempt
to get as much as we can.
It's the age of the ego. It's the time when
we're saying, what are my quotas? What's in
it for me? What can I get? And we go through
that stage. And I believe that I was writing
earlier in my life to teach people how to
be better athletes and better warriors, because
that's where I was in my life in those days.
And the shift has taken place for me as well.
Yung said that the third, uh, archetype is
what he called the, the, uh, archetype of
the, uh, of the statesman or the stateswoman.
And this is when we finally get to a place
in our adult life, when we stop saying, what's
in it for me? How much can I get? How much
can I accumulate?
And we begin to ask the question, how may
I serve? What are your quotas? And serving
others becomes much more important than our
own egos, until ultimately we reach what he
called the stage of the spirit, the archetype
of the spirit. When we finally begin to recognize
that, that this is not our home, what it means
in the Holy Books when it says, you are in
this world, but you are not of this world.
And these four stages, represen. Also where
we can look at our own self. How am I doing
going through these? To what extent do I find
myself consumed with my own quotas? What's
in it for me? How much can I get and ask ourselves
that question as we begin to interact and
deal with other people being able to manifest,
being able to be attracted into our lives,
what it is that we'd like to attract into
our lives?
Boils down to a formula that I'd like to share
with you here this evening. And this formula
is one that everyone that I know who is able
to get things into their life practices. This,
I call it the four releases, all right? So
that what you really, really, really, really
want, you will get. And these four really
stand.
Each of them stands for something. And if
you look at people who are good at, some people
call them lucky, some people call them highly
spiritual, whatever it might be. But they
are good at getting what they want in their
lives. And here are the four releases. The
first one says, I wish. So what you really
wish for, everything that you'd like to get
into your life starts with a wish.
It's a thought. I wish I could get that job.
I wish I could get that promotion. I wish
I could lose weight. I wish I could get rid
of that addiction that I have. I wish I could.
Whatever. It's a wish. So what? You have to
start with a wish. The second really stands
for what you desire, what you really wish
and desire, and the difference between what
you wish for and desire is in what I call
asking.
Ask. And you shall receive. Ask and you shall
receive. It's not empty words. Be willing
to. . When I get stuck sometimes writing and
I just not quite sure where to go or whatever,
I just leave the typewriter. I leave the yellow
pad that I'm writing on. I walk over to the
couch and I get into a meditation and I say,
I would like some help in having this become
clearer as to how to express it.
And it's always there. Sometimes the phone
will ring and my wife will call and she'll
say, did you know that this was in the mail?
And I'll say, read it to me and it'll be exactly
what I needed. Sometimes it just comes in
the mo in the thing that I call an intuition
or an insight, whatever it might be.
The third really stands for what I intend.
So now you shift away from what I wish for
and ask for, and you frame it in such a way
that you intend to create it. I intend to
create this, whatever it might be, whether
it's a healing, whether it's a, uh, losing
of weight, whether it's getting rid of an,
an addiction, whether it's creating prosperity.
I intend to create it. And if you notice,
people who are good at manifesting, they don't
mince those kinds of words. I will do it.
And someone will say, well, what if it doesn't
work out? You say, well then I'll just learn
whatever I have to learn from it not working
out, but I intend to create this in my life.
There's an intention, and the intention is
so powerful that you become independent of
the good opinion of other people. You're not
checking it out with the tribe. You're not
checking it out with what everybody else out
there said you should do or shouldn't do.
You're saying to yourself, I intend to create
it.
And I often tell people, don't tell anybody
else about what you wanna manifest. Don't
make it a big statement. Instead, keep it
to yourself. And they say, why do you wanna
say that? I say, because the minute that you
do, you invoke ego. And in quantum physics
there's a simple line. It says Particles themselves
are not responsible for their own creation.
Another way of saying that is the way St.
Paul said it, that which is seen, he said
half not come from that which death appear.
That is the source of everything over here.
It's not over here. It's in this invisibleness.
And once you invoke ego, you have to defend
it, you have to explain it. You have to get
the tribe involved in it.
And before long, you've lost the capacity
to manifest. It's a spiritual journey in inspiration
in spirit when you're inspired in spirit.
The fourth really stands for passion. Passion.
That is, I am absolutely passionate about
it and I intend to create it with that luck.
One of the great books that one of my teachers
sent to me from Ancient India, written like
3000 years ago, has a line in it that says,
to attempt to manifest what you want without
passion is like dressing up a corpse.
So you take this corpse and you put a tuxedo
on it, and you dress it all up and you put
all the makeup on it, and you take it out
into the world and you say, now see what you
can get for me. But basically it's dead inside.
And if it's dead inside, that is if it lacks
passion. If you lack passion, you're not gonna
be able to attract it into your life.
So what you wish for, ask for, intend to create
and have passion about. You'll get, you'll
get it. That's the good news. The bad news
is that what you really, really, really, really
don't want you will also get, and this is
one of the most difficult things for people
to understand. And when you're dealing with
the tribe and you're dealing with what is
and what, uh, what everybody else tells you
is impossible.
And somebody might be watching this and say,
well, that's just a lot of nonsense. I mean,
you can't just put your attention on something,
think about it and have it come true. It involves
a whole lot of other stuff like that. You
see, here's how it works. You cannot attract
thin from, I hate being fat.
Because if what you think about is what expands
and what you're thinking about is hating being
fat, then hating being fat is what you will
continue to manifest. You act upon what you
think about. You cannot attract prosperity
from an inner consciousness that says, I hate
being poor. I despise being poor.
Because if you despise being poor, if you're
angry about being poor, then being angry about
being poor or despising, it is what you will
continue to act upon and you'll be able to
say, see, now that's, it gets worse. , you
cannot manifest what you want. If your attention
is on what is? If your attention is on what
is and the circumstances of your life, that's
where your thoughts are, then you will continue
to create what is into your life.
You've gotta figure out a way to get your
mental images, your energy, your attention,
your higher awareness off of what is and onto
what you want. And every time your thoughts
are on, what is you shifted to, what do I
want?
And it's even worse than that, , you cannot
manifest what you want. If your attention
is on what always has been. This is the way
things are. You'll hear people say it to you
all the time, these are the circumstances
of life. Don't you understand? This is reality.
Wake up. These are the way things have always
been.
There's always been poor people. You are one
of them. . That's just the way it is. And
you watch that person and being poor continues
to manifest into their. If you keep your attention
on what always has been, then what always
has been is what you'll continue to manifest
as you think so shall you be. These aren't
empty words, folks.
This is reality. And the worst and ugliest
of all is this. You cannot manifest what you
want into your life no matter what it is.
If your attention is on what they want for
you or what they expect for you, or what they
tell you are your limitations or what you
can do. Because if your thoughts are on what
they want, you cannot put your attention on
what you want.
What they want will continue to manifest,
and you might be in a tribe that always turns
left and all you wanna do is make a right
turn. And you go to all the tribal elders
and you say, look, I just wanna make one right
turn. And they say, wait a minute. In our
tribe, we only turn left . We've always turned
left.
That's the way this tribe has always been.
And so they will have an emergency meeting
and they will convene all of the elders to
get you to come to your senses. Jackson Brown
has what I think one of the great poets on
our, on our planet, great singer. He has a
song called For a Dancer. In there there are
words to this effect.
He says, just do the steps that you've been
shown by everyone you've ever known until
the dance becomes your very own. Which is
what most of us are doing. We're doing the
steps that we've been shown by everyone we've
ever known, and the dance has become our very
own. And later on in the song, he says something
to the effect of, into a dancer, you have
grown from the seeds someone else has thrown.
Go on ahead and throw some seeds of your own
somewhere between the time you arrive and
the time you go home. And then the kicker,
it always gets to me when I listen to this
song, he said, because in the end there is
one dance. you'll do alone. And it's like
letting go of this tendency to be a dancer,
to be doing the steps that we've been shown
by everyone we've ever known.
And then it becomes our own, and then we pass
it on and we pass it on to break that chain,
we have to shift our attention off of what
we don't want and onto what we do want. And
this goes for everything. I was at a, doing
a book tour up in Chicago. I get off the airplane
and a woman picks me up and she's got a doozy
of a cold.
Like, you know, Snoopy's is, my kids call
it, coming out of her nose onto her drive.
I mean, it was, and I was in a, in this little
Honda with her for two days, . And she, so
I said to her, something to the effect, I
can't remember what it was. I, I, I know she
didn't like it, but I said something to the
effect of, oh, it's been 20 years since I've
had a cold like that,
And she said, oh, that's just what I needed
to hear
It's people like you who go around telling
us normal mortal human beings that when we
have a cold, we should be feeling guilty.
She said, I don't appreciate that at all.
She said, colds are just things that happen
to us. I said, well, I understand that. I
said, but I just don't think like you. She
said, well, what do you think?
I said, well, tell me what you think. You're
the one with the cold. She said, well, I think
colds are viruses and that they're in the
air and they're gonna land on us every once
in a while, and when they do, we shouldn't
be feeling guilty about it and feeling bad
about it. And people, you are like you writing
books about it to make us feel worse.
I said, look, we're on the same page here.
I said, I believe just like you, I think that
colds are in the air and that they're viruses
and that they land on us. She said, well,
how come you don't get a cold? I said, because
when they land on me, I talk to them . She
said, you talk to viruses? I said, of course.
She said, well, what do you say?
Well, I say to her, look, you've landed on
the wrong immune system. . I'm not gonna talk
about you to anyone. I'm not gonna complain
about you. I'm not gonna give you any attention
and you no room to flourish on this immune
system. You're just not gonna do your work
here. But there's a lady in Chicago,
who's waiting for you. . Now you laugh and
you think that that's silly, but I'm telling
you that when you keep your attention on what
you don't want, what you don't want is what
will keep manifesting into your life. Addictions
have been described as never getting enough
of what you don't want or what you despise.
So we keep our attention on what we don't
want, and what we don't want is what we keep
seeking after, and then we despise it when
we put our attention on what we do want. When
we shift to a place called unconditional love
and begin to view it as something that I don't
have to be dependent upon, you can shift right
out of it.
The currency for attracting what we want into
our lives is our thoughts. As you think so,
shall you be? Begin to place them on what
it is that you want and you'll start seeing
it shift over and over again. And people who
are terrific at getting what they want, you
start getting inside of their head and say,
what do you think?
Like what? How are you organized in here?
And you know what they always say, I never
ever allow my thoughts on anything that I
don't want. And no matter who out there is
saying Yes, but you can't do this. Yes, but
you can't do that. I never allow that kind
of energy. I don't. I shift away from that
energy instantly.
That's what separates great masters from ordinary
human awareness. I have been talking during
this program about a consciousness, an awareness,
a level of functioning or living or thinking,
which involves something that I call spirituality.
It doesn't, it doesn't, it isn't restricted
in any religious way.
It is a divine intelligence, an organizing
intelligence that is everywhere at once. Some
people call it God. Some people call it soul,
some call it spirit. Back in the times of
slavery, there was a young man, his name was
John Newton. He was 23 years old and he had
what is called a in Japanese. It's called,
uh, excuse my Japanese, but it's called
I'd love to say that. sti, S a t o r i. And
it means instant awakening, the idea that
you can create something in your life. Now
in Zen, they have a proverb that says, when
the student is ready, the teachers will appear.
So it's just being ready. And so you don't
have to go through this long involved process
to get to enlightenment, where you get it
five minutes before you die.
Instead, you can have it when you are ready.
The Native Americans, they have a word called
in the Ute Indians And it means great seeing,
like I don't see, I don't see, I don't see
an boom. There it is. I see. And it's like,
it's like in a dream when you just have this
awakening, this light goes off and you just
know it's in intuition, if you will.
Intuition has been described as, you know,
if prayer is you talking to God, then intuition
is God talking to you. It's like hearing that
voice and you know it. And John Newton, this
23 year old sea captain had a, uh, a ship
full of, uh, human cargo that he was bringing
from the west coast of Africa to the new world
as slaves.
And he had this sat, this awakening. And in
this moment of awakening, he realized that
what he was doing was horrible and defenseless
in terms of his own inner sense of morality.
And he wrote down on the envelope, the words
to a song called, he called it Grace. I once
was lost and now I'm found. And it was Grace
that taught my heart to feel it was grace
that brought me home.
He shifted away from his material world and
his, his being a warrior, to being a spiritual,
being in an instant, which is available to
every single one of us. There have been things
that, uh, have been showing up in my life
and principles for me to write about and,
um, things for me to tell you and share with
you that have, um, um, that have really surprised
me.
And I've always lived by the principle of
T lopa, the 10th century Sufi master who said,
have a mind that is open to everything and
attached nowhere attached to nothing. And
my wife and I always had this, um, attitude
in, in bringing up our children that, um,
keep an open mind and anything that, um, you
immediately reject, get your ego out of that
and just open yourself to the words of Jesus
in the New Testament when he said, with God,
all things are possible.
And I always ask my audience, uh, what does
that leave out? What does all things are possible
leave out? And obviously the answer is nothing
in the book that I wrote. Um, for the film,
the Shift, there's also called The Shift.
Um, it has four chapters from ambition to
Meaning, moving our lives away from our egos
and into a place of, of meaning.
What Serena was up here speaking about. It,
it's a sense of feeling that you're making
a difference in the world. And towards the
end of that book, I quoted from, um, a man
named Joel Goldsmith, who wrote The Infinite
Way in parenthesis in Eternity. And we actually
had friends on Maui, a friend on Maui named
Alexandra, who was in her nineties.
And in her late eighties, she would go out
kayaking every day, . And she actually dated
Joe Goldsmith back in the 1950s when he lived
on Hawaii. He's been a very much of a hero
to me. And then from his book, parenthesis,
parenthesis in Eternity, which is which what
Your life is a parenthesis in eternity. He
said these words, he said, then there are
those who reach a stage in which they realize
the futility of this constant striving and
struggling for the things that perish things,
which after they are obtained, prove to be
shadows.
It is at this stage that some persons term
from this seeking for things in the outer
realm to a seeking for them from God. And
that has been probably the major shift in
my life, taking the focus in my life off of,
um, the things, the accomplishments, the acquisitions,
the reputation, ownership, which we begin
to identify ourselves as.
And to begin to recognize that, uh, Pierre
Te Yard, the great French priest who was excommunicated
from the Catholic Church for his outrageous
ideas in 1918, um, he said, you're not here
as a human being. Having a spiritual experience,
that it's the other way around. And you've
all heard it, that we are all infinite spiritual
beings, having a temporary human experience
and beginning to live our life from this spiritual
place.
It's place of spirit where we recognize and
identify ourselves not on the basis of what
the ego says, which is on the basis of what
we have and what we accomplish, what we own,
and what others think of us, not based on
our belief and our separation from each other.
And most egregiously not based upon our belief
and our separation from God, a shift, if you
will, to an awareness of, uh, of our own divinity.
And from that place, what is possible for
all of us. So I'm going to recite up home
here from a, um, a great poet. His name was
Samuel Taylor Calk. He, um, he wrote a poem
called The Rhyme of the Ancient Mariner, and
he also wrote one that wasn't that well known.
I put it in a book of mine years ago called
Real Magic.
I started it with this. And I'd like you to,
as I give these words, I I'd, I'd like you
to think about what the poet is asking and
whether or not you believe in your heart or
know in your heart that what I'm, what the
poet is saying is possible for you, or whether
you think it's just the fancy kind of, uh,
fanciful, um, meanderings and dreamings of
a, uh, of an idealist.
Ask yourself, does this possible? He said,
what if you slept?
And what if in your sleep you dreamed and
what if in your dream you went to heaven and
there picked a strange and wonderful flower,
and what if when you awoke, you held that
flower in your hand? Ah, what? Then he concludes
his poem. Ah, what then I wonder if you think
such a thing is, um, is really a possibility
that you can go into a state in which there
is no form, no beginnings, no ends, no boundaries,
no limits, and bring from that invisible place,
something that has substance, that has boundaries,
that has formed that you can hold, that you
can smell, and then ask yourself if that's
a possibility.
I wonder how many of you think yes, and how
many of you think no, I, I'm not gonna ask.
But um, the fact is that, uh, this room has,
it looks like 2,500 or so people in the room
tonight. Um, every single one of you are an
example of what that poet just described.
Every single one of you came from a formless
place and are now form all of you, every flower
that you look at.
Began in a seed, and the seed began in something
that is invisible.
There's a little girl here tonight, Camille.
Where's Camille? Six years old or so, seven
years old. I was, I was swimming with her
a little while ago, and she showed me her
teeth and she said, uh, I lost two of my teeth.
And look, there's two, two teeth coming underneath
it. And she was all excited about that.
And, um, I said to her, mom and my daughter,
summer, who was here , um, just imagine that
in that tiny little infinite infinitesimally,
small little speck that built into that was
what she's going through right now. What is
there to do?
There's nothing for us to, we could, we can't
make a change in that tiny little invisible
speck. Everything that you needed for this
physical journey was handed for you and you
don't believe in miracles. And the great Dow,
many of you know, I lived, uh, the Dow for
a year, the year I turned 65 and wrote a book
on it.
A book that I always tell people, carry it
with you wherever you go. Some call it the
wisest book ever written. And, um, I lived
the principles of that little book and I encourage
people to, uh, to just stick it in your new
purse.
the ones that are made out of plastic, recycled
water bottles. Is that all right?
and um, But just carry it with you because
you don't even really need to, uh, open it,
cuz the energy from what's in here will come
to you. I had a great teacher in India used
to say, he wrote a, uh, uh, a, a collection
of his writings was called, I Am That by,
uh, Nagata Maharaj. And he used to say to
his devotees, you don't have to read it, just
carry it with you.
And I heard that I was in my early forties
when I heard that. And I just thought, this
is just another one of those crazy guys over
there in India giving us advice. And, uh,
I just didn't think that it would be possible
to get. But now I've really come to an awareness
that, uh, energy is in everything and that,
um, just holding this book, literally you
could, you could muscle test this kinesiology
and, um, put this thing next to your heart
and you will be stronger with it than you
were without it.
Just try it, just carry it with you. Let me
see who would like a copy of this? Oh, that
hand right there. The first hand up there
you? Yep. No next to you. Yeah. Stand up.
Would you like to carry this with you? Wherever
you go, there you are. God bless you. The
Dow to Ching. It's only a few dollars. It's
worth having.
One of the great lines in the Dow is what
I'm speaking about here at these opening lines
is that, um, it says that none of you are
doing anything. You're all just being done.
And when you look at your physical body, there's
a recognition that this is absolutely true.
You know, I mean, what can you do to change
it?
You know, things are drooping, folks. , you
can fix 'em up if you want to, but, uh, the
inevitable is there. And the hair, well, for
some of you it turns gray and for some of
you it just turns, it just goes somewhere
else. And, um, you begin to. See there's also
a great line in the book because my son, who's
sitting in the front row, uh, sands, who graduates,
uh, in a couple of weeks and is gonna start
supporting me, I'm so happy about that
Um, cause I often have quoted Latu and he
has often said the Dow God divine mind, the
Dow does nothing
and it leaves nothing undone. It's all perfect.
So I say to him, when, over the summer, over
in Maui, I said, Saint, come on. Do something.
You gotta do it. Let's go. We gotta do something.
He looked up me and he said, I do nothing
and I leave nothing. I'm undone . So this
cuff can come back at you . It's his favorite
line now, dais philosopher.
So the great saint, uh, Swami Mok Ananda,
um, was asked the question, what is real?
And his response is really worth you hearing
and something for you to really think about
because the, the strange place that I think
it's weird, it's just, um, it's just so magical,
but it's still just, it's hard for us to wrap
our arms around this idea that all things
are possible.
Uh, this, this, this awareness that, um, that
about what is real and Mok Nandes said that
is real, which never changes.
So what part of your physical life meets that
definition?
We are all in. , these, uh, bodies that are
changing every second. Therefore, by that
definition, they're not real. So you go back
and, um, look at how many bodies you've been
in since you showed up here. You were in a
body about this big that weighed somewhere
between five and 10 pounds, and that was you.
And you were in a little toddler body about
this tall.
And you certainly, if someone said, is that
you, you would've said, yeah, that's me. And
then you were in a 13 year, 12 year old body,
which is, um, one of these, I have six daughters
and they have a stance, you know, and they're
about 13, and they go like this, and their
leg goes up and down and they roll the rise
and look at you like you ought to try to get
a life someplace
You were in one of those bodies, teenage body,
and you thought that was real. That's when
you get the great learnings. One of my daughters,
Serena said to me one time when I raised my
voice and asked her to hurry up and get moving.
Come on. She looked at,
I wonder what all those people would think
of Mr. Positive if they could see him here
this morning,
she turned to her sister and said, uh, would
you buy a book from someone who yells at his
11 year old daughter? I, I sneak out of the
room and try to, best line I ever heard from
many of my children ever, and I follow them
around with a pad of paper do to give me material,
was for my daughter summer when she was 13
and her sister was 11, sitting at the breakfast
table and all of a sudden about six 30 in
the morning and summer looked at Serena and
said, well, If you didn't have any feet, would
you wear shoes?
Serena, at that time, and it hasn't gone away,
um, could hardly stand anybody talking to
her at six o'clock in the morning and said,
that's the most ridiculous thing I've ever
heard you say. We don't even talk to me. Why
are you, why are you just don't even talk
to me. Close your mouth. Why are you talking
to me?
That's so stupid. When even didn't have any
feet, would I wear shoes? Of course not. And
some looked at and said, don't get mad at
me. I just wonder why you're wearing that
bra that's, uh, . So
I you were in one of those bodies,
I was in a 20 year old body. And, um, I saw
a picture of it on the PBS show and I was
doing a little bit of this, and the pictures
of me at various stages of my life were going
by. And the film was, uh, uh, the camera was
looking at this picture and it stopped on
a picture of me when I was about 20 years
old and I'm 70 when I was 51 years ago.
And, um, there's not one cell of that body
left on this planet . I really thought it
was real. And when you were in your 20 year
old body, you thought it was real, didn't
you? I mean, it's just like you'd look at
it, he said, of course it's real. And now
you look back at it and you say, if it was
real, where is it
and where did it go?
Emily Dickinson, another great poet, one of
my very favorite poets from Massachusetts
would, um, would give talks back in the 19th
century and she would pick up a handful of,
of dirt and she would say, just let this in.
This quiet dust was gentlemen and ladies and
lads and girls was laughter and ability and
sighing and frock, frogs and curls.
This passive place, a summer's nimble mansion
where bloom and bees fulfilled their oriental
circuit then ceased like these.
That's who you are. If you believe that you're
your body, just quiet us. That's going to
fulfill its circuit and cease. And we all
know that we're something much more than that,
but we haven't been raised to believe that.
So my talk tonight is really about understanding.
There is a component of us that is beyond
the physical meta, beyond the physical metaphysical,
um, beyond form trans over past higher than
form transformed.
And this, um, this part of who we are has
infinite possibilities and can do anything,
can heal, anything, can manifest anything,
can attract into our lives, the right people.
And you get a sense after a while that, um,
that this invisibleness that is who we are,
is as, as you begin to elevate your awareness
and move to a higher level.
And, and this is basically the essence of
it. It's that
we were all conceived and born into a world
and a culture in which we were raised to be
ordinary. And ordinary isn't so bad. I'm not
here to put down ordinary and average and
fitting in and all the things that ordinary,
uh, comprises. It's just not what I want for
me. And I got the mic tonight, . So an ordinary
really means, um, it means fitting in.
It means getting along. It means becoming
a good citizen. It means, um, filling out
the forms. It means paying your taxes. It
means having your children and providing for
them and taking care of them, and, uh, going
to work, going to school, and getting good
grades and graduating and your family, and
doing all of this,
all of this, these ordinary things. And then
getting to the, uh, later stages in your life
where you become a grandparent and then you
live your life through your grandchildren
and then you die. And, and this isn't an,
an indictment of that. It's um, , it's for
me an awareness that if I put my hands here
about at my waist, I am speaking about ordinary
consciousness.
And where I would like to take you tonight,
where, where I have been taken in my life,
particularly in the last year or so, and particularly
in the last decade or so, um, is to a place
that I call extraordinary awareness. An extraordinary
awareness is, um, it encompasses all of ordinary
so that you're listening to an ordinary man.
I fill out the forms or I get somebody to
do it for me. more like it. Um, and I pay
my taxes. And, um, I've provided for all of
my children. And, um, and I went to school
and saw that they went to school and was there
for them as much as I could be. And, um, did
all of the things that we would say constitute
ordinary, but extraordinary doesn't, doesn't
stop here.
See, this is where it stops for so many people
and they go through their life with this.
Um, remember the Barbara Streisand song? Is
that all there is? And there's this, the sense
that, uh, that there's more, there's a calling,
there's something in me that is transcends
the physical. Let's, Fran sends ordinary.
And this something that, um, wants to move
us to this extraordinary level out here is,
um, is beyond the ego. Everything I've spoken
about here is, is the ego. It's the striving
for it's, um,
it's, it's an identification and a belief
in my identity as a physical being and believing
in what my physical self tells me is my reality.
And evaluating it on the basis of what I can
see and touch, and feel and smell and hear,
so that it's my senses, my, my sensory self
is here. But this up here between ordinary
and extraordinary, where I believe anyone
can go at any time.
Here we are. What Ee Cummings, another favorite
poet. He said, to be nobody but yourself in
a world which is doing its best night and
day to make you just like everybody else means
to fight. The greatest battle there is to
fight and never stop fighting. This is how
the poets think. It's about going beyond average.
It's about going beyond ordinary. It's about
recognizing your own divinity. It's about
understanding that there's something inside
of you that is calling you. It's your spirit.
It's your soul and your soul. Your spirit
is here in the distance between here and here,
and your soul wants something very, very different
than your physical body ego apparatus wants
it.
It's really, it's not interested in fitting
in. It doesn't care whether you're right.
It doesn't care whether people like you. It
doesn't care about whether you're a good citizen
or not. I wrote these words out the other
night. Let me share them with you.
It says, I said the ideal cause. I'm gonna
write about this, the ideal of the soul. The
thing that it asks for is neither knowledge
nor light, nor happiness. The ideal of the
soul is space. The ideal of the soul is I
amenity. The one thing it needs is to be free,
to expand, to reach out. To embrace the infinite.
Yeah. The ideal of the soul is infinity. It
is. It is miserable. When it is circumscribed
and restricted. The soul is not finite. What
is finite? Finite means it has a beginning
and it has an end, doesn't it? So it's, that's
it. It stops here and it's finite It. The
opposite of finite is in finite. Infinite.
And what is infinite?
What does it mean when something is infinite?
It means that it is always expanding, right?
It doesn't stop anyplace. It is always growing.
It's like the universe, it's just infinite.
What do you think's at the end of the universe?
Just try to imagine a finite universe. And
we come up with, well, what would be at the
end of it?
And what we think is at the end of it is what?
What is there? A wall. And if there's a wall
at the end of the universe, the poet would
ask. What's on the other side, , and where
does that end? So there's getting in touch
with this infinite part of ourselves is really
the part of us that says, there was a song
that was popular when my mother was a young
woman.
It was called Don't Fence Me in . Oh, give
me land, lots of land. And the starry skies
above. Don't fence me in. Remember that song?
All the old folks singing , my daughter's
looking at me. What is he gonna do now he's
gonna embarrass me. , we don't wanna be fenced
in. Now, before I had any children, I had
eight theories about how to raise children.
I even wrote about them. Now we have eight
children. I have no theories, , but the one
thing I know about raising children is this,
that nobody likes being told what to do. Right?
Sage, I was telling the story of, uh, you
Honey, um, on Mother's Day, one year at a
restaurant where we were all there and my
mother, Marcy's mom and dad, and we were all
there.
And, and, um, Sage is, um, in a lot of ways
like me, the, the, what I call the, I tell
this story at every talk, so I might as well
hear is the scurvy elephant. When I was in
the foster home back in Mount Clemens when
I was about six or seven years old, I came
home from school and Mrs. Scarf who ran this
home, had this home that where a bunch of
us lived.
And I came home and I asked her, what's a
scurvy elephant? And she said, A what? And
she said, A scurvy elephant. , I mean, I said,
and she said, well, where did you hear that?
I said, well, I heard Mrs. Poole, who was
my third grade teacher talking to the principal.
And she said that, uh, Wayne Dyer was in her
classroom and that he was a scurvy elephant.
So she got on the phone, called the principal,
and the principal said, oh no. And she said,
that's Wayne. He gets everything mixed up.
She didn't say that he was a scurvy elephant
in her classroom. She said that he was a disturbing
element in her classroom, and I always loved
to say that , so a scurvy elephant is, uh,
and my teacher, Abraham Maslow, which does
always say to us, um, you know, the, the number
one marker of self-actualizing people is their,
uh, their independence of the good opinion
of other people.
They're just not interested in being told
what to do. I watched on the, um, on my iPad
, which I just got, um, and it, um, it had
a, uh, a commencement addressed by, uh, Steve
Jobs, uh, at Stanford University. It was a
15 minute, and I just sat there and before
I meditated, I listened to what he had to
say, this immensely scurvy elephant who really,
I mean, just passed away a few weeks ago.
And, um, you know, many his biographers now
saying that he's up there with, uh, Thomas
Edison and Benjamin Franklin and, uh, Alexander
Gray and Bell, people like that. I mean, he
really changed who we are as a people and
how we communicate with each other. And his
advice to the whole graduating class at Stanford
was, don't live somebody else's dharma.
Don't listen to that inner calling and whatever
it calls you to do, listen to it. And don't
pay attention to anybody telling you what's
possible or what's not possible, just fight
for it. Sage was at Mother's Day, and I don't
even remember what it was that she wanted
to wear or didn't wanna wear, but um, it had
something to do with dresses and skirts and
slacks.
And I remember that Mother's Day walking in
the parking lot with Sage for 45 minutes or
so talking to her about, um, I know exactly
how you feel and how you think. I said, but
there's a lot of people who think that you
should maybe wear something nice. It's Mother's
Day and it's a restaurant. I said, but, uh,
you don't have to go back in there.
We'll go home and get something afterwards
if you want. And, uh, she just gimme that
I don't want to do this, and why should I
be told what to wear? And I understood that.
I understood it very strong, and she's still
doing that.
But it also serves people very, very well.
This idea that, um, I'm gonna listen to that
voice and we all have it. And when we have
this voice and this voice has passion associated
with it, that is when you feel a strong passion
towards what it is that you want to become,
what you want to create, the kind of person
that you intend to, to be, when you have that
within you, um, it doesn't make any difference
whether anybody else understands it or gets
along with it.
You don't even try to talk to anybody else
about it. You just listen to it and you become
a disturbing element. You become a scurvy
elephant in the world. And, and it's the only
way you'll ever feel fulfilled. You won't
get it by, by fitting in. So in order you
have to listen to your soul. And your soul
is that invisibleness and your soul is not
finite.
Therefore, everything up to here is finite.
Everything that I spoke about, filling out
the forms, fitting in, being a good citizen,
doing all the right things, all these things
which I applaud, which are all fine, but they
only take you, um, you end up living a half
lived life.
Herman Melville, I spoke about him this morning
when I spoke to the writers group here. I
mean, his writing was so profound and so beautiful
and he uh, he had this one line from Moby
Dick, which is really not the story about
a man chasing a whale. It's a story of, um,
a person who has an obsession and that whale
is a symbol of, uh, I must achieve it.
I've read a really great book this summer.
Every one of my kids have read it, and it's
called Unbroken by Laura Hill Hillebrand.
And, um, I recommend that you read it and
wherever this is going around the world, get
a copy of it. It's the story of Louis Zamperini
who, um, survived on a raft across the ocean
and was taken to a Japanese prisoner of war
camp and on and on and on, and survived against
all odds.
And that at the end was able to go back and
forgive. I mean, it's a just a powerful, beautiful,
spiritual experience. And, um, and Ahab was,
uh, was pursuing his own, uh, inner voice
that just couldn't be stilled. And this is
how Melville spoke, cuz I live on an island
in the middle of the Pacific Maui. Where I
invite you to come in January to listen to
the whales, go on a whale watch with me.
And if you like what I'm speaking about here
tonight, we do 3, 2, 2 or three days on it
in January. Here's Melville. He said, for
as this, a ocean surrounds the verdant land.
So in the soul of man lies one insular, Tahiti,
full of peace and joy, but encompassed by
all of the horrors of the half lived life.
The half lived life is the life that gets
you to ordinary, to filling out the forms
and then stopping the self-actualized.
Life starts at ordinary and listens to its
soul, which you can't find, but you know,
is there and there are some that doubt that
it's there. I had a friend who's a neurosurgeon
over in Maui, and he was saying, you know,
you talk about this soul thing a lot. He said,
I've poked around in a lot of human brains
and I've never seen a soul or anything resembling
a soul
And I asked him, I said, Chuck, I said, um,
while you're in there poking around, have
you ever seen a thought
Well, no, of course not. I said, do you think
there are thoughts, that such a thing as a
thought exists? You can't see it. You can't
touch it. You can't. The fact is that virtually
everything that exists is metaphysical beyond
the physical. It's very limited, our physical
world, and it's not even real.
Standards because it's always changing. The
body that you came into this room with will
be a different, you'll leave in a different
body. There's something called you that just
keeps occupying more and more and more new
bodies until ultimately it just sheds it all
together.
The great Irish poet, William Butler Yates
said, um, an aged man,
his but a poultry thing, a tattered coat upon
a stick. What an image. Unless soul claps
its hands and sings and louder sings for every
tatter in its mortal dressed. We're just tattered
coats on a stick unless we have a soul. And
when we have a soul, the soul says, don't
fence me in. The soul says, don't tell me
what to be.
Don't tell me what I can't do. Don't you dare
impose upon me who you are and what you think
I should be? That's your soul. And all of
you have this cuz this body of yours is just
an illusion. It's just a very temporary parenthesis
in eternity, isn't it? And you know that you're
gonna leave it and all the evidence is there
and you just keep looking at it.
You try to pretend that it's not there. And.
So you color the gray, the color of the gray,
and you lift them up and you shift it around
and you put on a girdle and you do all of
the, I don't know, you do all of the stuff
to pretend that it's, and you're not doing
a damn thing in this world. You're just being
done
You're just being done. But what you're being
done by is the higher self. So what I would
like to offer you here is a, um, a program,
if you will, it's sort of a preview. I've
been reading and studying and, um, lecturing
all over the place for the last year or two.
And for some reason I've been given a, a,
a big voice and a, uh, a big audience.
For some reason, I'm, I'm allowed to, uh,
go on public television and, and present in
primetime three and four hour specials on
the Dowda Ching or on the power of intention
or on changing your life, living from a spiritual
place. And, um, it must be because I've had
this, um, wonderful opportunity handed to
me that, um, I've been getting exposed to
more and more and more, but about, um, the
miraculous power that comes to us when we
start our life from ordinary and just leave
that part of it to be taken care of and move
into this extraordinary place, this place,
um, that all the great writers speak about.
Where we, where we transcend this ego, this
ego of ours that, um, believes that who we
are is so important and believes that who
we are is what we own. And who believes that
what we are is in competition with others
and has to defeat others and has to win and
has to, has to be better than I love the poets.
I feel very poetic tonight. Uh, a great, um,
Indian poet named Ramnath Tagore won the,
uh, Nobel Prize for literature in 1927 with
a collection of poetry called ga. And in there
he writes about this ego of ours. He says,
um, I went out alone. It's on my way to my
tris. But who is this? Me in the dark? I step
aside to avoid his presence, but I escape
him.
Not He makes the dust rise from the earth
with his swagger. He adds his loud voice to
every word I utter. He is my own little self.
My Lord, he knows no shame, but I the invisible
me. I am ashamed to come to theor in his company.
That's the ego, the part of us that makes
the dust rise from the earth with our swagger,
who's always adding his loud voice.
But inside there's this being that says, um,
who I am is so much more than that, so much
more divine. And in order to get to the path
of moving towards extraordinary, and the fact
is that, Even though many people will attend
to talk like this and many people will buy
the books and uh, and study it and look at
it, the percentage of people who are willing
to leave ordinary behind is very, very small.
Honestly, it's only a handful of people in
this room, even though the intentions are
good. The, um, the book that I'm reading now,
I came across a quote, um, I think I'm gonna
read it if I have it here. Ah, here it is.
It was by a, a French, um, philosopher, mathematician.
Some of you studied him when you took a philosophy
class.
His name was Renee Decart. He's the one who
said, I think therefore I am, I don't like
to question these guys. I used to teach them
at the university, but I think he headed backwards.
. I really believe it should be. I am. Therefore,
I think, well, that's just my opinion. I'll
talk about it later. And Des Hart said, in
order to reach the truth, it is necessary
at some point in one's life, to rid one's
self of all the opinions one has ever received,
and to rebuild one's entire system of knowledge
from the very foundation.
And I think I've done that recently, just
tossed out. I think this diagnosis of leukemia
two years ago really helped me to do that.
And to just say, I'm starting over. I'm going,
I'm going here. And I've been doing it in
some ways. Many of people think I've done
it my whole life, but honestly I haven't.
I've walled around in that ego a lot in my
life.
Um, and, and so. In order to do this thing,
you have to recognize that it fundamentally
involves changing your concept of yourself.
And changing your concept of yourself really
means understanding what is your concept of
yourself? Like, who are you? What is your
concept of yourself? Your concept of yourself
is everything that you believe to be true
about yourself and what's possible for you
and anyone else.
And it really means changing most of that
because you have been raised to be ordinary.
You've been raised to believe in your limits
and how far you can go. And you've been have
this imposed upon you by your well-meaning
parents and grandparents and culture and religion
and business and education. Uh, the systems
that you have been immersed into have basically
told you, get here.
This is not for you. And it might not have
even been done. And sometimes they might have
even said, oh, you can do anything. And then
we'll start to tell you all of the reasons,
all of the exceptions to that, that I'm imposing
on you. Like you gotta get dressed in a certain
way for Mother's Day , and you've got to fit
in and you've got to do this and you, and
it's by, by God.
It's um, it's like the soul has no finiteness
to it. It it, it's infinite. So it means it
just wants to keep expand. It wants to keep
growing. Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed the video. I'd love to
know what you think of it. Leave your comments
down below so I can, uh, get your feedback
and work to improve for future videos.
I'd also love to know what lessons you learned
that were most impactful from this video,
leaving the comments, and I will join in the
discussion. Finally, wanted to give a quick
shout to Madeline Murray. Thank you so much,
Madeline, for picking up my book. It really
means a lot to me. For those of you watching,
you want a chance at a shadow in future videos
as well as some awesome bonuses, make sure
to pick up a copy of the book and email in
your receipt so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching. Continue
to believe or whatever your one word is, and
I'll see you soon.